That's a fake-out.
You don't have a loop.
You don't get no loop.
You guys didn't notice.
Sorry, I had to close my door.
But I've been trying.
I've been trying to do... be more active on Twitter.
Being a content creator by tweeting out that I'm live now.
So that's why it took me a while to swap scenes.
But yes, welcome back to Elden Ring.
So it's been a while since the last time we played Elden Ring.
And I've forgotten all my controls.
What's even worse is that I'm going to go back to Controller.
And by saying go back, I'm going to relearn this game.
But on Controller.
Even though I was playing on mouse and keyboard controls earlier.
So the reason why...
For those who didn't know.
Because I was explaining it in a non-Elden Ring stream.
The reason why I'm not playing on M&K anymore.
Is because after part one of Elden Ring.
My hands started cramping up.
Afterwards.
So I realized that I can't play Souls-like on M&K.
Because my hand hurts.
So I gotta play on Controller.
I think it's just...
I think it's the movement.
When I have to...
I think...
I don't know.
Maybe it's the sensitivity.
But like...
I don't remember which hand it was that started cramping up.
I think it was...
I don't remember.
I don't know if it was the keyboard hand or the mouse hand.
But something was fucking with me.
Later on.
Because I didn't feel it when I was playing Elden Ring.
It started happening like...
After.
Like after a little bit.
And then I...
Like I was trying to play...
Like I think I was trying to play like Rivals or some shit.
But I couldn't.
Because my hands were cramping up and stuff.
And I was like...
Like you know...
The worst part is that...
It doesn't cramp up.
I've done like 16 plus hour Marvel Rivals streams.
But I've never had like...
A cramping issue before.
And I've done like...
I've like...
I've had problems with my wrist before.
When I...
In Overwatch.
When I had to do like...
Six hours of scrims.
And then rank in Overwatch.
And then you know...
Obviously you shouldn't...
And then I had to do that like...
Back to back to back.
And my wrist started like...
Feeling really sore.
But I've never...
Like I've never had an issue with...
My fingers...
Starting to cramp.
So I don't know why.
But it's only happened...
In Elden Ring.
I've never had that happen before.
In any other...
In any other game.
So like...
I was like...
Okay.
We're gonna play with controller.
Because I don't...
I don't...
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna deal with that.
Party ball.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki tweeting live now.
No way.
I know.
Right?
It's crazy.
Because I was like...
Oh man.
I should really...
Be more active...
On social media.
I've yet to...
Go to the stage...
Where...
Um...
Where I start like...
Replying to people.
Because like...
That's a little bit too much for now.
We're...
We're taking baby steps here.
Okay?
Like...
Ha ha ha.
That's a little bit too much energy...
That I don't have at the moment.
So...
We're gonna...
We're gonna take...
Little baby steps.
Like sharing that I'm live now...
Is like...
A giant leap of progress for me.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gave up on M&K so quickly.
Roller on Apex.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
There's no like...
Life update or anything.
But I really want to talk about this...
Before we start with Elden Ring.
But like...
Uh...
There were like...
Apparently new updates...
On the new Donkey Kong game.
And like...
People are like...
Fucking...
Freaking out.
Because like...
There's...
They just dropped so much lore.
And like...
Lore and content.
That everyone's like...
What the fuck is this?
And so like...
Apparently in the new Donkey Kong game...
Uh...
Pauline is in it.
The thing about...
That...
Is that...
Um...
She's like a child now.
So like...
Everyone is like...
Super fucking confused.
Because...
Uh...
Okay.
So...
They're like...
Okay.
That makes sense.
Because the Donkey Kong...
That kidnapped Pauline...
Is...
Um...
Donkey Kong's...
Dad.
So like...
Cranky Kong.
So...
Um...
So like...
Maybe like...
You know...
That's why...
Pauline and Donkey Kong...
Don't hang out anymore.
Because his dad...
Kidnapped her.
And then like...
So like...
They're like...
Trying to like...
Figure out...
How the fuck does this work...
In the whole lore...
And like...
Timeline...
Of...
Mario.
And...
So then...
But then the thing is...
They showed a...
Screenshot...
Of...
Donkey Kong's dad...
But he's like...
Super fucking old.
So everyone's like...
Okay.
What the fuck?
It's like...
Okay.
Now that's like...
Weird.
Like...
How...
Is this like...
An alternate...
Cinematic universe?
Uh...
Like...
Is this like...
Are we in like...
Are we not in the main...
Mario timeline?
Are we in like...
An alternate...
You know...
It's like Zelda timeline...
Like a little...
There's like a little fucking...
Time paradox right now...
Are we in like...
Some like...
Is this like a Zelda timeline shit?
Where like...
Every version of Zelda games...
Or like...
Legend of Zelda games...
Is like...
A different version...
Of Link and Zelda?
Like...
No...
We don't know...
Like...
It just...
This entire new...
Donkey Kong game...
Like...
Um...
Ruined...
The whole timeline...
And lore of Donkey Kong...
Like, we don't know what's going on anymore in the DKverse.
So, like, people saw this screenshot in, like, the Donkaverse.
Like, it was, like, all our theories, all, like, everything we know about Mario doesn't make sense anymore.
Like, like, everyone's like, oh, yeah, it's Donkey Kong's dad that kidnapped Pauline.
And that's what, like, Mario is trying to save Pauline from Donkey Kong's dad.
And then now you're like, wait, but Donkey Kong and Pauline are working together?
And they're actually close friends?
But then, like, okay, so, yeah, but that makes sense.
Like, maybe that's why they're not close friends anymore, because his dad kidnapped her.
But then, but then, why is Donkey, why is Cranky Kong so fucking old in the screenshot?
Then who kidnaps her?
Like,
who the fuck is, who the fuck kidnapped her?
Oh, yeah.
By the way, Donkey Kong wears clothes now, because in the game, um...
In the game, they started, like, kink, like, sorry, kink-shaming Donkey Kong for being naked all the time.
Because all his, all the other Kongs wear clothes.
And then Donkey Kong wears, like, a tie.
And then, like, apparently there's, like, an outfit selection.
And then in the outfit selection, they're, like, Donkey Kong is naked just like the way he was born.
But then you can give him clothes.
Like, apparently his default isn't, like, isn't naked anymore, because...
Because he, he started, like, kink-shaming him.
He's...
Donkey Kong is a free spirit.
Set him free!
He doesn't need clothes!
But they called, they basically called him a nudist.
And I was, like, what the fuck is going on?
I, this, this new Donkey Kong game, like, it's...
It's, like, everything you knew about Donkey Kong is not...
Like, what's the word?
It basically, like, changed everything for all Donkey Kong fans.
Everything you know is gone now.
Also, apparently he can turn into a fucking ostrich.
And a zebra.
Like...
Like, what the fuck?
I'm so confused!
Why can Donkey Kong turn into a fucking zebra?
I...
And he can fly?
Like...
Yeah.
Alright, yeah, I'll show you guys...
I'll show you guys a clip.
So, like, whenever...
I think it's, like, whenever Pauline starts singing...
He, he can turn into a...
An ostrich gorilla.
And I'm...
I don't know.
It's, it's...
It's really fucking cursed.
Like, um...
Like, look at the...
Okay, the ostrich gorilla looks...
It looks so fucking wrong.
Because the ostrich gorilla has, like, fucking muscles.
Like, he's, like, buff as hell.
And...
But then, like...
His wings are feathers?
Like, I...
Sorry, sorry.
His...
Not feathers.
His wings are fingers.
But, like, there's feathers, too.
It's so cursed.
I, like, saw a screenshot.
Like, I saw the video.
I'm like...
What the fuck am I...
What the fuck am I looking at?
I like how someone was like, that's somebody's type.
Oh, but don't worry.
They...
They included...
They made sure to include at least one furry bait in there.
And I'll show you a picture of her.
You'll...
You'll know exactly.
Okay.
These are apparently the villains of the new Donkey Kong game.
And, like...
And I'm like, guess which one is...
Guess which one's the furry bait.
One...
Oh, yeah.
Their name isn't...
Her name isn't that.
So, okay.
Okay.
So, there's, like, a viral tweet going on where they're...
They're like, oh, yeah.
I can't believe...
Like, these are the villains of Donkey Kong.
And then everyone thought that her name is...
I can't say it.
I don't have an Australian to give me a pass right now.
But...
Everyone thought that that was her name.
Because of this one guy.
Like, everyone got one guy.
And...
Her actual name is...
Poppy Kong.
But, like...
If her name was like that...
I...
Will not...
I don't know.
It really fits.
I won't be surprised if her name was actually that.
And I'll be like...
I'll be like, wow, Nintendo.
I never thought you'd be progressive for once.
Um...
But...
But, yeah.
Anyway.
Oh, so I'll show you guys the description of this.
I love this.
I love this description.
Uh...
And there's...
Oh, yeah.
Never mind.
Nintendo wasn't actually kink-shaming me.
It's like, it's okay.
Naked as the day you were born.
And there's nothing to be ashamed of.
So, apparently...
He's just...
He's actually just walking around naked.
Uh...
It feels like...
If you're the best nudist Nintendo...
Uh...
Why is it not default?
Apparently...
Him wearing pants is the default.
I mean, in the trailer...
In the trailer, it's all, like...
Um...
It's all, like...
Uh...
Donkey Kong with pants.
So, like...
I assume that...
Like, being naked is not default anymore.
But he has...
Alright.
But would you...
Okay.
But would you go out in public wearing just a tie, though?
Um...
Okay.
But yeah, that's...
I really wanted to talk about...
The new Nintendo Donkey Kong game.
Because, like...
That...
Those up...
I don't know.
When they...
When I saw all the tweets...
And...
All the tweets and all, like...
Um...
The news about the new Donkey Kong game.
I felt like my whole world view was shattered.
Like, everything I know just was not true anymore.
Like, I...
Like, I thought I knew...
I thought I was confident in my...
Mario Donkey Kong lore.
But apparently, Nintendo was like...
Was like...
Bam!
Dropped, like...
In a fucking hidden bomb that exploded...
And destroyed all the lore that we knew.
Uh...
They fucking flipped the table.
Like, I don't know...
Like, I don't know if this is the main timeline.
Or if we're in the alternate universe.
In the Donkiverse.
I don't know anymore.
Like, everything I know is a lie now.
Uh...
Yeah, I need like a Donkey Kong multiverse diagram.
All theories were wrong.
Goodbye.
Now.
Also, I ordered from Uber Eats.
I trusted Uber Eats one more time.
And I got really sad yesterday.
This is a sad update.
For my life update.
But basically...
Um...
Uh...
Basically...
What?
Oh, sorry.
I got a message.
I'm gonna put you on a cliffhanger real quick.
Uh...
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry.
Okay.
Anyway.
Life...
Sad life update.
I ordered from Uber Eats.
Because I was craving mac and cheese.
But I was craving like...
The homemade style type of mac and cheese.
Where...
They have like...
You know...
Chopped hot dogs in it.
The...
You know...
Like the actual homemade style type ones.
And...
Um...
Like...
I don't know.
It's just a little...
Little plus.
You know?
Just a little...
Little like...
Just...
I don't know.
It just feels so much better.
When a mac and cheese have like...
The classic chopped hot dogs.
Anyway.
So...
Um...
I ordered it.
But like...
I ordered it where it was like...
Meat lovers combo.
So it would have like...
Pepperoni...
Chopped hot dogs.
And bacon.
And like...
I was like...
But what I was craving for the most...
Was the chopped hot dogs.
I got it.
And it had everything...
But the fucking hot dogs.
I'm so sad.
That was like...
The one thing I craved.
I was so fucking upset.
And hot dogs.
And pepperoni.
And bacon.
But where were my hot dogs?
I was literally...
That was the only thing.
If they didn't include the pepperoni...
If they didn't include the bacon...
I would have been fine.
I would have been...
So okay.
But no!
The one thing I wanted...
Was not there!
I couldn't even complain about it.
Because I was so hungry.
I was like...
Om-yum-yum-yum.
Maybe the hot dogs...
Are like...
On the side.
Like on this side.
And I was like eating.
I was like...
Where's the hot dogs?
And then like...
There was like...
One third left.
And then obviously...
I was like...
Wait.
There was no hot dogs.
So I like, I like fucking went to the Uber Eats app and I was like trying to complain and like take a picture of the food.
But then like, obviously, one third of it was fucking gone already.
So I was like, okay, like if I, if I take a picture of this, they'll just think I'm lying.
They'll just think I like, I just wanted a free refund.
Yeah, it was too late already.
I have one third of the fucking mac and cheese left.
So I was like, they'll just think I'm fucking lying if I took a picture of what I have left.
So I, I didn't get a refund or a complaint.
It was a little bit too late.
I was like, yum yum, maybe the hot dog is over.
I don't know, I thought the hot, I was, it looked really good and I thought the hot dog pieces were like, I was just missing it, you know?
I was just like, wow, I can't believe I would coincidentally just miss the hot dog pieces when I started eating.
I was like, maybe it's on this side.
It was like, om yum yum.
I was like, wait, it's still not there.
Maybe it's on this side.
And I finally realized after there was one third of it left, I was like, wait a minute.
There was no hot dog pieces in the end.
I was like, wow, I can't believe they put all these hot dog pieces on the one side I didn't eat.
That's where my brain went to.
So I had that.
Also, Overwatch update.
I want to talk about this.
I want, I'm going to be a drama alert.
Sorry, I thought this was really crazy.
So I really wanted to talk about this.
But drama alert.
We're going to be a drama channel for like five minutes.
Because I thought this was absolutely insane and a little funny.
But also not funny because it's fucked up.
But like, I don't know if you guys remember who, I don't know if you guys know who Kefri is.
But back in the Overwatch days, he used to be like this Widow, Widowmaker streamer.
That all he'll do is just one chick Widowmaker.
He's an asshole.
But he has a lot of like drama associated with him.
And throughout the years of playing Overwatch.
Overwatch, it's crazy shit.
Like if you ever go into the fucking Kefri Overwatch rabbit hole.
You're going to find some fucking crazy shit.
I know a person that was in that Discord call.
Where they were reading out the DMs.
If you know what that means.
You know exactly what I was talking about.
When I say all of that.
Anyway, so, um, so his ex-girlfriend, um, like his ex-girlfriend, like they broke up.
And, um, that was, I don't know.
It was surprising, but also not surprising due to the person Kefri is.
And, um, and she revealed that he cheated on her with multiple Instagram girls.
And, um, what was fucking crazy was that, uh, apparently, um, he made her sign an NDA.
But by getting, by being in a relationship with him, she had to sign an NDA.
So where the fuck happens?
Like in that relationship.
And when they're broken up, she can't reveal anything.
And then, apparently, anyone that interacts with Kefri in DMs or privately has to sign an NDA to even interact with him.
And I was like, holy fuck.
Like, I was like, you cannot have a conversation with him privately, like in Discord or on Twitter, without signing an NDA.
That's absolutely crazy.
I was like, holy fuck.
But like, okay, it's sort of understandable because you got, there was so much drama leaks come.
Because I believe it's because there was so much drama and leaks associated with Kefri, that at that point, he was like, if anything gets leaked, he can legally sue you.
Oh my god.
Like, he got too many DMs leaked that now he needs to be sure that no one can ever leak anything from him again.
It seems like he has too many secrets.
No, this guy, he quit his job working for the CIA to become an Overwatch streamer.
Like, that guy, he like, I think it was like the CIA and like, some, yeah, he was, he used to work in the CIA.
So, yeah, that's why he does so much shit.
He quit working in the CIA to become an Overwatch Widowmaker one trick.
Um, I mean, like, do what you love, you know?
Like, like, chase those dreams.
The natural progression.
Of course, the dudes are fed.
Oh my...
Yeah, an NDA for you, girl!
Nefret is fucking crazy.
Okay, I can understand a little bit of this.
Because, I heard in the, the, the sports scenes, like, for basketball players, and like, um, for basketball players especially, because like, people, and like, um, football players, because they make so much fucking money.
Um, the reason, apparently, like, if you pay attention to basketball or like, American football, you will notice that a lot of them date, like, some, like, the same girls.
So, like, like, like, one girl would be passed around different, like, uh, basketball, NBA, and NFL players.
Because, like, they're, like, they're, they, like, sign NDAs when they get into a relationship with them.
Um, so, like, they always, like, they date the same person, because they, they already know the process of, uh, they already know the process of dating, like, a sports celebrity.
So, they don't, they don't have to worry about, like, her leaking anything.
So, so, like, you know, if she gets broken up by a different, by, like, her boyfriend, then she'll date another, like, football player or a basketball player.
So, like, they're, like, oh, you already know the whole process.
So, like, you know, you have to sign this NDA and that NDA.
So, and I know you don't leak anything, because you used to date this basketball player.
And I know you don't leak stuff, so I'll date you next.
Like, so, so, like, it's, like, a common thing within that scene.
But it's just crazy to hear, hear that in, like, I guess, like, in esports in general.
Because it's, it's fucking esports.
Like, it's, it's just, he's not even a pro player, you know?
Jeffrey's not even a pro player.
He's just, he's just a content creator.
So, it's weird to hear that in, like, content creation.
And, like, as a content creator, too.
But, but yeah, anyway.
Anyway, that's my drama alert for the day.
Let's actually play Elden Ring.
I just, I really, I just really wanted to talk about it.
It just blew my mind when I was reading about it.
Um, Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine giving up a career in the intelligence community to be an Overwatch streamer.
Name a worse trade-off.
Okay, to be fair, at that time, at that time, he was the number one Widowmaker at that time.
He, he used to have, like, before, like, people realized he was, like, an asshole.
Like, okay, to be fair, on his stream, everyone knew he was an asshole.
But, like, he was really, really good at Widowmakers.
So, people were just, like, giving him the pass.
But now, now people were like, wait, oh my God.
You're a little bit weird, too.
Like...
Anyway, uh, guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, Doki, you do, you know too much.
Aren't you breaking an NDA?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was lucky enough to be one of the people who has never ever interacted with Kefri, personally.
Thank fucking god.
I have- I am one degree separation from- from Kefri, though, because I know someone who was- I know someone who knows someone- wait, no, two degrees of separation.
I know someone who knows someone that was part- that was in those DM leaks.
Hahaha!
The original DM leaks.
And I know more details about the first DM leaks than any of you guys know that I can never talk about in public.
Hahaha!
That was actually one of the people involved in those DM leaks.
I know too much.
And I wish I didn't know this information.
I- I- I don't- Toki, don't get near the window, Toki!
Um...
Toki, you have to avoid windows now.
Hahaha!
I- I wish- I didn't know some of the information that I know, because it's like- You know, it's like those types of info where you're like, why did you tell me this?
Like, I don't want to know about this.
Hahaha!
And then- And then- I also- know, like- Um, one of my friends have seen the pictures.
And then they're like- Hahaha!
They're like, I wish this picture was never sent to me.
Hahaha!
So- The pictures!
Uh-huh!
Okay.
If you know the lore- the lore behind it, then you'll know- Oh no!
What- If you know the Kefri rabbit hole drama, then you'll know exactly what I'm talking about when I say pictures.
Hahaha!
So- This is like the context for like- This is like- The people who are still- Who still remember ancient Overwatch lore.
It's actually like a throwback in history.
Hahaha!
Nitro!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
This is a wild start to this stream.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Start!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
The pictures!
What do they- You don't want- You don't want- Hahaha!
Literally- The people- People who know the ancient hidden lore.
Wish they didn't know the ancient hidden lore!
Anyway guys, let's play some Elden Ring.
Um, it took me a while to boot up the game at first.
Because, it- For some reason, It went to my third monitor.
So like, I was trying to figure out how the fuck to get it back to my first mon- The third monitor, which is the vertical monitor too.
So it was like a little- Like, a little bit- Uh, A little bit troublesome to like, play on that monitor.
Um, Yeah, you guys are all like- The ones who get to live in blissful ignorance.
You guys avoided one of the darkest times in Overwatch history.
Uh,
It's- Clearly- It was pretty funny.
Okay, It was like- At that time, I- Oh my gosh.
When those messages got leaked, There were some wild fucking phrases in there.
Some wild shit in there.
At that time, it was pretty funny.
Because you're like, I can't believe he said that.
Coolen, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
These pictures sound cursed.
He let me know where to find them so I can avoid them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll just say that the original messages that got leaked had the pictures, but it was censored.
But my friend, one of my friends saw the picture uncensored.
That's all I'll say.
The ones that got leaked to the public were censored.
Oh shit, not my flask.
Okay, I need to know how to play this game.
Wait, did I boot up?
Okay, I thought I was in Night Ring for a sec.
Doki, please, I'm scared.
Please, he used to work in the CIA, Doki.
Stop!
That's okay, I live in Canada.
They can't get me.
I live in Canada, guys.
Alright, let's... I forgot to like put the game on stream... on screen.
Alright.
Okay, I need to remember how to play this game, guys.
I actually don't know.
Okay, that's the sneak.
I don't know how to play it on a controller.
Uh, okay.
Guys, how do I make it so like... okay.
How do I... okay guys, I have an Xbox controller, guys.
Okay.
How do I make it so I hold this sword to hand?
I...
How do I... I have... I'm on an Xbox controller right now.
Uh, Y plus RB.
Okay, that's not it.
Oh, I forgot I rebinded everything.
I thought that... do my things rebind?
Do my things rebind if I...
Okay, wait.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, operate.
Okay, it doesn't.
Thank God.
Okay.
It doesn't rebind.
Wait, why doesn't it work?
Why am I not holding it two-handed?
Oh, I can't do it on the round table.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I have to leave the round table.
Okay, I just gotta figure out how to leave.
Alright.
Where is safe?
Wait, what's that?
Where is a safe place?
Okay, we gotta go to the tutorial.
Is that the cave of knowledge?
Okay, there we go.
We'll go back.
We'll go back to the tutorial.
Doki, the CIA works outside of the US.
No, no, we'll be fine.
We'll be so fine.
We'll be safe.
Okay.
Alright, there's that.
Okay, and then...
Okay, two-handed.
Alright, and then...
Oh, shit, guys.
Guys, stop.
I'm okay.
Don't appraise yet.
So you can appraise me later.
I don't know why it still says mouse and keyboard.
What's this?
How do I do this?
Oh, okay.
That's how I do it.
Okay.
And then...
Okay, and then that's block.
And that's where I'll do that.
That's where I use the octopus.
Okay, and that's...
Okay, and that's my last.
And then that's jump.
How do I roll?
The f...
Oh wait.
Oh there it is.
Okay, that's how I roll it.
Alright.
Okay.
Guys, I figured it out.
It's been 64 years.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Why does it keep saying E?
Okay.
Oh, I forgot.
I need to put my death counter on.
Give me a sec.
Death.
Alright.
There you go.
My death counter should show up now.
I think.
Where was it?
Was it this?
Oh, there you go.
Eleven deaths.
Oh, is it graphics?
Oh, okay.
Let's change our system.
Where is it?
HUD.
It's not eleven deaths!
I had to go to tutorials so I could live!
So I could be alive!
Okay, there you go.
I have to relearn my controls!
I don't want something to, like, come up when I'm trying to level up.
When I'm trying to relearn my controls, guys.
Okay.
Uh...
Where the fuck do I go?
Do I go here?
Where I killed him?
Oh!
Okay, we have to go...
To where I killed the lion.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't remember.
Was it here or do I have to go to the lion?
Where did I kill him?
It's been so long.
Did I level up yet?
Alright, let me double check.
Okay, I did.
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
I think it was...
Here?
Right?
No, that's the bridge.
Where the fuck did I kill the lion?
Do I just remember?
That one?
Right here?
Okay.
This is where I killed him.
Alright, I don't know how many bosses I'm gonna...
beat today.
Alright.
I remember how...
But at least I remember how to play the game.
Can you sprint in this game?
Or is that just Night Ring?
Here?
Yeah.
Here it is.
Hold B?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I can.
It's hold B.
Oh, wait.
This giant's dead.
Who killed him?
Who killed this guy?
Let's go.
Okay, here we go.
Is it worth killing him?
Is it...
Is it worth killing?
Oh my god!
Okay, there's several.
Okay.
Wait.
I can summon...
My little...
Oh, whoops.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry!
Oh, I didn't even use that!
Okay.
I can summon...
My little...
Okay.
Let me...
Let me go heal.
Alright.
Okay, apparently they're not worth it.
Let me heal real quick, guys.
Let me...
If they're...
If it's not worth it, let me just...
Let me just heal real quick.
Alright.
Now.
It's rewind time.
It's...
Tactical...
Reposition.
Yeah, but like...
Now they'll be asleep again, guys.
They'll be asleep.
That's what we wanted.
Now that they're asleep, I can make my move.
Alright.
Full reset.
It's like nothing happened.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?!
There's so many.
Oh my god.
Why did I go that way?
Oh!
Don't worry, I have a rock.
Okay.
Maybe I should worry.
Maybe... Maybe I should...
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
What's this?
Examine.
Yes!
Goodbye.
That's right.
Can't get me now.
Oh, I have a horse.
I forgot about him.
What was his name again?
I forgot he existed.
How do I summon him?
Is that him?
Wait.
No.
Is that him?
Where is he?
I forgot he existed.
What?
Bro, I've been, like, walking this entire time.
I mean...
Oh, I can't summon in here.
Guys, I've been actually walking this entire time.
Let there be wrath?
Ah, you don't have the right...
Right of what?
Lack of information.
Poor!
Alright, open.
That's right.
The information was...
Too poor.
Something incredible.
Oh, something incredible.
What is it?
What is that?
Why is he 2D?
Hello?
What's going on here?
Why is it always a liar?
Wait, is there nothing...
Important?
I'm so confused.
What's going on?
Oh!
I'm going up!
Why are these black blobs 2D?
Oh my god, this is the longest elevator.
Wait, that means I can bait someone to come down here and then he'll fall to his death.
Eh?
What does it say?
Time for head.
Time for head?
Wait, is it just head?
Wait!
Really?
For free?
Oh, hey!
There's another grease!
Alright.
Let's see...
Do I have any extra?
Anyway...
Oh, I do!
Yeah!
Wait, why is it 6?
Why does it say 6?
Oh!
Oh, not enough.
I wasn't reading.
I got too excited.
I thought it meant I did have to.
I got too excited, guys.
Bloodsting, don't you dare!
No necessary item ahead?
Too high up?
Oh my god, why are all these ominous messages?
Oh...
Still no head.
Okay, guys.
Let me put my influencer build right down here.
Let me...
Ahaha!
Ha ha ha ha ha...
Time for head!
Ahaha!
There we go!
I'm gonna praise this message.
It's time for influencer build.
Alright.
If only I had chaos.
Be wary of fingers.
Oh.
Restore the power of the great runes.
Oh, Godric's great runes.
Oh!
Wait, that's the guy I killed!
Finger.
Oh, my God!
He does have no head!
Okay.
Wait.
Actually, no.
This one.
This is better.
There you go.
Right here.
For anyone.
Please.
Save this man.
Gorgeous.
Time for tranquility.
Okay.
I think this guy got baited.
Where do I do it?
Here.
I am not gonna jump.
Liar ahead.
Guys.
I feel like all of these is telling me not to jump.
That's it?
Oh.
Just leave.
Okay.
Do a flip.
Alright.
I'll go back to the divine tower.
Wait.
Do I go back to where I killed that other guy?
Do I just go back?
Oh, my God.
How far did I go?
It's like actually TP.
Do I just go back here?
Okay.
Yeah.
This is where I beat him.
Oh.
I can see a rune thing?
What's that?
Is this great runes?
Oh, there it is!
That there.
You can use...
Oh.
Oh!
Nice.
Raises all my attributes.
Let's go.
Hello, sir.
Yes.
You are.
You're a free boy now.
He gave you a sock.
Yeah.
Alright.
You're a free man now.
What's this?
Silver pickled file feet.
Anything that's worth buying?
Material used for festering bloody fingers.
Oh, there's like all the invasion stuff.
Yeah, no.
I don't trust you, dragoons.
I feel like...
Yes, I'll invite co-op.
But I feel like...
I feel like you will all invade me more than help me.
Oh, this is mostly PvP?
Alright.
Let's go over here.
Still no tarnish.
Oh, well done.
But just getting started.
I know you dragoons.
If I was a fucking god at Soul's Leg, I would definitely invade too.
Behold, victory.
Left.
Oh, this way.
Okay.
What's over here?
Seek head.
Left.
Okay.
This...
This way is left.
Wait, but what's over here though?
What's over here?
But Doki, you can be better if you invade more.
Yeah, I feel like, you know...
I feel like you dragoons and playing Soul's Leg for maybe like...
I don't know, five plus years?
Like how...
When was the first Dark Souls game up?
I feel like you guys might have...
May or may not have more experience in Soul's Leg than me before I could fucking catch up.
Oh, left.
Left again?
I always left.
It's been...
Oh my god, it's been like...
Almost...
Fifteen...
Yeah, you guys have been fucking grinding, so it's like for almost fifteen plus years.
I don't trust myself against you guys.
I have no confidence.
Whee!
Oh, is this a friend?
Behold, fruit.
Oh, it is fruit.
Nice.
Hello?
Are you okay?
Only eleven years.
I know, Doki.
It's so little.
I just...
I'm just a new player.
Eleven years.
Where the fuck is the secret passage?
Then...
Behold...
Okay, I'm getting invaded.
I feel like there's nothing here.
I feel like I just have to go this way.
Liar.
Yeah, I think he's lying.
Ah, comfort.
Am I supposed to feel safe here?
Oh, no.
I don't feel that safe.
Why did so many people die here?
What happened here?
There's...
Everybody do a flip?
This is the flip code?
Like, was there a meaning I wasn't aware of?
Oh, they were trying to...
Oh, I see what they were trying to do.
Oh!
They tried to parkour.
Oh, they failed the shortcut.
I see.
It was a shortcut they were trying to do.
Oh, there's a grease here.
Little lemons.
They're like, I saw this on a YouTube video once.
I could do it, too.
Where do I go?
It's your turn.
They failed to get the beef.
Oh, is this my goat?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
No, I ruined my no-goat speedrun.
No!
My speedrun!
It's ruined!
My no-goat speedrun!
Oh, nice.
I got a secret tier.
Wait, who are you?
Okay, now I gotta restart.
Yeah, that's me.
Then, perhaps you could spare some runes.
Believe it or not, I studied blinstone sorceries at the Academy of Rhea Lucaria.
For a small donation, I'd be happy to share my knowledge.
What does he want?
Do I have ten runes?
What are runes again?
Is it worth it?
I don't even think I have ten runes.
Oh, my solos.
Oh, I have ten solos.
That's pretty cheap.
Oh.
He's asking for ten cents.
Or you could step on a rat and get ten runes.
If I study...
If you want to play magic, you can learn a bit.
Do I need magic?
No, magic is for pussies.
Yeah, magic's for the fucking weak.
Yeah!
You know what?
I'll even kill...
What if I kill him?
You know what?
I'll show you how much I don't need...
What if I just kill him now?
I...
Whoa!
Save the archer.
I'll show you what I feel about magic.
Whoa!
Now, hold on.
Optional, but...
Don't kill him.
He's...
Whoa!
Stop!
Alright, let's see.
I got...
I saw...
I saw the speedrunners with magic.
I...
I know what they did.
You...
Oh!
Yeah!
That's it!
I don't like being called a coward!
I'm going back!
That's right!
You tried to rage bait, and you rage baited successfully!
I'm coming!
No!
Alright!
Wait, what does this say?
Wait, no.
I wanna read what this says.
Alright!
Give me a reason why I should spare his life!
Right now!
Don't!
Oh, thank you.
That's enough reason.
Money is enough reason.
Bye, Talon!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Your lucky money is enough reason.
Oh, shit!
Alright, nice.
What's that?
Is that gonna explode?
Oh!
I have to double kill him!
Mike, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Do it!
Zyko!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Back in my day!
Old days!
Magic invasion!
Especially Moonville!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
How did you die?
Oh!
I see!
Oh, I see!
Oh!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I see now.
Wait, can I, like, hit that?
Or do I have to dodge?
Okay, is there a range, though?
Okay, watch this.
Nice!
Oh, wait, I should double kill him, just in case.
Wait.
Get out of here!
What the fuck?!
I said GET OUT!
Okay.
There we go.
There's a double kill.
I guess that was a bleed.
How come you screwed up?
Where do I go?
I forgot about locking on.
Alright, nobody did a flip here.
Except for this guy.
What the fuck?
Is that another shortcut?
Oh!
That's another shortcut.
Do I do a flip here?
Yeah, but do I go up, though?
Alright.
Is that...
I'm okay.
Where's the river?
I did something that no one else could do, chat.
I'm gaming.
Wait, what's over there?
Never punish.
Do I go up here?
I think we're going down now.
Look at that.
I'm a natural parkourer.
Wait, I don't know which way to go.
I go up here.
Yes, you go there.
Okay.
I couldn't tell.
Do it again!
Guys, I think I'm at one life now.
I...
I think...
I'm pretty sure I'm on one life now.
Is he gonna do a walk forward?
My eight lives are gone after that one jump.
Wait, he has magic?
Fucking pussy.
What the fuck, you pussy?!
Oh my god!
Get out of here.
Can't believe it!
You brought a sword!
I thought you were a real man!
That's it!
Okay.
Fine, I got it.
Alright.
Nice.
The magic rock.
Is there another one?
Okay.
I'll do it one by one.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Slowly walk up towards me.
Come on.
Come on, a little too slow.
Okay, you're...
Okay, stuck by a jar.
Okay, now I definitely know you're not a threat.
Oh shit!
Alright.
Okay, he is, like, blocked by a jar.
Like, he is not a threat.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Come on, swing that sword.
Come on!
That's right!
Come on, swing that sword again!
My turn!
Oh!
Get out of here!
Nice!
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Do it!
Alright, I guess I go forward.
Uh, not-so-deadful!
Oh, hey!
There's that guy.
Oh, I could've just...
I could've got backstabbed.
I'm pretty sure.
Behold, Rump.
Uh, by the way, Doki, if you ever want easier from soft games with sexy robots, you should check out Armored Core.
It's the most accessible, but Last Raven is the easiest one.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Visions are plump.
One day.
Alright, let's head this way.
What's that over there?
Oh, is this a river?
That people told me to follow?
There's a grace here.
Wait, who was that guy fighting?
There was a- there was something that guy was fighting.
Who the fuck was he fighting?
Wait.
Oh, is that- Oh, I should do that, right?
When the fuck did I get Sacred Tear?
Did I use it?
I don't know when I- Oh, in the church?
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know if I'm, like, accidentally using something I shouldn't.
Oh, is he trying to kill this po- this merchant?
This- This small business owner?
Oh, hey, nice.
It's really a butterfly.
I can't believe it!
He's trying to kill this small business owner!
Don't you take a look at my wares?
Oh, but...
Don't ask me how I got my hands on them, eh?
Don't worry, I'm also a murderer.
Uh...
Oh, I need that.
Do I have one yet?
Do I have a lantern?
I'm always blind.
I feel like I don't.
Oh, I need that!
Yeah, I'll get the lantern.
Yeah, I feel like I should.
Oh, lantern crafting kit?
Oh, I'm too- Wait, I don't know what it is, but I'm too poor for that.
Alright, equipment.
Where the fuck's my lantern?
How the fuck do I equip that?
Put it on here?
No, that's not it.
It has to be inventory, then.
Oh, there you go.
Use.
Nice.
Alright, I don't know if it'll always be there, but...
Oh, should I put it on my hotbar?
Oh, I could!
Let me try that.
Uh...
I don't want to put it on my hotbar.
Oh, there it is.
Uh...
Wait, what?
Oh, switch.
There you go.
Wait, no.
You just follow this river?
Hey.
Did I steal your horse?
First off, here.
And then try a horse.
Oh, what's up here?
Alright, come over here, horse.
What's up here?
Where do I get up here?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Horse parkour.
One of the hardest parkours out there.
But don't worry.
I'm a natural.
If only I had ladder.
Wait, what do you mean wasted time?
Oh, no.
I'm okay.
Okay, I'm not gonna try that again.
I...
I don't think I'll try that again, guys.
I don't think...
I don't think that was worth it.
What?
Oh my god!
My horse!
Oh!
Please!
Someone embrace new head!
Thank you.
There you go.
Nothing to worry about.
Nothing to worry about, guys.
Nice.
I got a map.
I...
The fu...
First off, map.
Where is this?
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
The heroes.
There you go.
My best build.
Hey, what is he ringing for?
Oh, shit!
Oh, that's what he's ringing.
He's ringing for it.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's right.
No magic here.
I kill all magic users.
Alright, let's grab this.
Okay.
I don't know why it does these mini setters.
I wonder if you could fix that, chat.
This is a little annoying.
It doesn't happen often, but it does get a little annoying.
Alright.
Oh, my flash?
Oh, wait!
What happened to my flash?
Wait a minute.
Wait.
What happened to my...
Wait a minute.
Wait.
What did I bind my fucking...
Oh!
So dumb.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Not the bear.
I was like...
There's no way.
When the fuck did I use the ball of my flash?
It's over there.
What the fuck?
Where were you?
Oh, my God.
You fucking whore.
He was like...
I like how he, like, waited for me to, like...
Figure out how...
Do I fight that guy?
Is it worth it?
Yeah?
You think he knows I'm here?
No, right?
Okay.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Wait.
Why is my...
Why is my octopus buddy...
My friend not coming over?
Wait.
What is he doing?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's fine.
I got so confused.
I was like, what the fuck was he doing?
But...
Alright.
That's...
Not as scary as I thought it'd be.
I...
No.
There's no summons here?
Okay.
I...
I was like, but he was on a horse.
I thought he was more impressive.
He was on a horse.
I didn't know he was pathetic.
That guy brought another player into the game.
Oh, nice.
I got a Firefly.
That guy.
Yeah.
To be fair, he did have Aura.
Alright.
Grace time.
Uh...
Enough for level up yet?
No.
I definitely don't have enough.
Oh, nice.
Another cookbook.
Yay!
Lobster?
Is he a nice lobster?
Hey.
That's just too late.
Where is...
Good luck, buddy.
One day...
Strong foe...
Ahead.
Therefore, try tree.
This tree?
Wait, where is he?
Oh...
No!
Choice!
Ahead!
Aww...
I don't know.
There seems to be a lot of dead bodies.
Aww, man.
Bro, what the fuck happened to him?
Bro, what the fuck happened to him?!
Okay, what if I go this way?
Should've he like...
Oh man.
Why go left or forward?
I'm so scared.
No, my chat died.
My chat.
How would I act?
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
My chat's back.
Think of the loot.
Wait, so I can't summon though, right?
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Where the fuck did this guy come from?
Excuse me.
Okay, I can see you.
My thing is locked.
Get over here.
I can see you.
I have locked targets.
You're not hiding from me.
Oh my god, please.
Get out of here.
Okay, nice.
Just go forward?
Okay.
Yay.
And brave Doki, it ran away.
I'm so brave.
Go left.
There's loot.
I'll come back.
Don't worry.
I'll come back to it, guys.
I swear to god.
And then she never came back.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
I will.
I'll be back there, guys.
Do not worry.
I'll make sure to come back for sure.
I'll be back there.
Hello.
Hi.
Maiden!
Over here.
Hello.
Hi.
It's rather chilly here, isn't it?
My mistress sent me off on an errand.
There's more than one maiden?
By a ruffian.
But you're blind?
Don't worry.
I'm very hot and sexy.
The hottest man you've ever seen.
Uh-huh.
What's up with your posture?
That's some gamer posture right there.
Hear the request?
Okay.
Oh, she said bye, not blind?
Oh, I thought she...
Oh, yeah.
She can definitely see me.
The thug should be resting at an abandoned home down the way.
Yeah, she knows where I am.
I must have the necklace back.
Okay.
Yeah, I can do that.
Snake the head, but try love.
Wait, she's a...
Lovable sort of head.
She seems pretty lovable.
Doesn't seem like there's anything wrong with her.
I'm a little lost now.
I strayed from the path and I don't know where to go.
I saw a woman and now I'm lost.
Wait, where are the lights that are supposed to take me to...
Where'd it go?
Oh, my map.
I forgot that existed.
Wait.
This is not helpful.
Wait a minute.
What the fuck do I go here?
Oh, no.
Where the fuck is the next map?
Well, then.
This way?
Oh, hey.
Oh, no.
I'm off path.
Yeah.
I'm off path, guys.
There's no messages to help me.
I'm off-roading it.
Yeah, but that's the...
That's the girl that needed my help.
No, these are my old arrows.
I made those.
I don't know how to take it off.
See?
One is like right over here.
I don't know.
Oh, I took it off.
The lob.
For some reason.
I don't know why, but...
I don't believe you.
Look north.
Okay.
In your back.
Go west.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
There's invincibility frames there.
That's good.
I like that.
Oh, my God.
He, like, slapped me for his final death.
Alright, get over here.
Okay, but not like that.
But, like, get over here.
Come on!
Get over here!
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Not like that, though!
Alright, it's okay.
That's okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, I'm lost now.
Oh, my God.
This guy disoriented me.
Okay, this way.
This guy, like, fucking disoriented me, so I didn't know where to go.
How did he die?
The fuck you just stood there?
Who killed you?
Death...
Oh, that.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, I think I might know who killed him.
I think...
I think I might know who killed this guy.
Yo, Wes?
Where's Wes?
Oh, there's Wes.
There's so many people died that way.
Oh...
I'm too scared to run!
I'm too scared!
Oh, wait, there's a...
Yay, there's a grease.
Let's go!
Yippee!
Never punish!
There's a shack!
Oh, wait!
There's lobsters!
See, I told you guys it can't be that bad.
What are you looking at?
You trying to start something, mate?
Give me the necklace.
That necklace, what you're after, is it?
Show me what it's worth to you, and I'll consider parting ways with it.
Wait, what do I have?
You don't have it or nothing.
Dear.
You're a shrewd one, Chief.
First, you hand me the runes.
And don't try nothing, neither.
Wait, all my money?
Wait, what?
Oh!
That's fine.
How fucking bad?
It's just a thousand.
Yeah, it's literally 1k!
I killed one guy with that.
Don't go crying to me later.
Alright, nice.
I did it.
Did I break into your house?
Okay, I just have to go back now.
Okay.
Oh my god, how do I go back?
I'm just like...
Where is...
Where is home?
I have a map!
Okay, I just gotta follow this.
Oh my god.
The one time I remember I have a map.
Map time, map time.
I have a horse.
I do.
I forgot he doesn't die.
But he died like one time and I thought he was just gone forever for some reason.
Oh, I could be his friend?
I like friends!
Alright, wait.
I'll talk to her and then I'll talk to him again.
I'll talk to her first.
Oh, I have to get off my horse.
The thug should be resting at an abandoned home, please.
Oh, here.
There you go.
Thank you kindly.
I am in your debt.
Did I forget to announce myself?
I am Raya.
In the service of Lady Tanith of the Vulcan.
Whoa!
I seek stalwart tarnished, who might join our house.
You are very brave yourself.
Not only a steady hand, but a steady heart.
Merciless.
Even to your own kind.
Wow, we have like the same posture too.
We're so perfect for each other.
Please.
Take this.
Oh!
Okay.
Grave tarnished.
Seek the Altus Plateau.
Oh my god.
I got an invitation, guys.
I'm going to go to a party!
An exclusive party!
Time to sign an NDA.
Ha ha ha ha.
But you are no ordinary tarnished.
And once that is proven, the Volcano Manor will fully extend its invitation to fight amongst a family of champions.
Oh!
Wait, to fight?
Wait, I thought this was a fun party!
Not a death party!
One more thing.
Only for you.
This land of Liarnia is connected to the Altus Plateau by the grand lift of Dectus.
Beyond the high road.
Wait, this is like...
It's like the island where they kill other humans.
There's no simple means of passage.
Instead, you must seek the old ruins in the cliff.
At the base of the valley.
Near the grand lift.
Oh my god, this is exclusive exclusive.
I have a fucking instruction on how to get there.
Linking Liarnia to the Altus Plateau.
I have faith in you.
A champion through and through.
I do hope...
All I did was get you a necklace.
How do you believe me so much?
I didn't even fight for it.
I just paid to win.
Alright, time to...
Wait, what the fuck is that?
I don't know.
What is that?
What the fuck?
I didn't see that before.
Alright, time to go back to the house.
I'm sure it's fine.
I can touch it, right?
Alright.
Time to find...
Okay, the house is in front of me.
Okay.
It's crazy.
I haven't found a single boss yet.
I've just been, like, exploring.
Do I have a grace here?
Oh my god, I could TP.
I forgot about the TP.
Uh...
It's not natural for me right now.
Man, I'm so hungry.
So very hungry.
It's so good.
Another price?
You could be persuaded to sell you some other bits too.
If you've got the runes.
Wait...
Purchase...
What is it?
Oh, it boosts physical damage.
Okay.
So you met the girl, did ya?
Alright, well...
Sod the particulars of the matter.
But it ain't my fault she's stupid enough to get duped.
Whoa!
Anyway...
She's just like me, for real, for real.
I thought you guys said he'll be my best friend.
How come he no friends with me yet?
Do I just go west?
Or west?
So many possibilities.
Oh, hey, Bandai!
Why suffer...
I gotta pay to be friends with him?
Oh my god, just like...
Just like real life.
I can't believe it.
Pay to win.
Alright.
Just like me!
Oh my god, now we're best friends!
Oh, spread out.
Wait, I just did like that.
I can't believe it.
I have to give him money.
Rent a friend.
Instead of rent a girlfriend, it's rent a friend.
About to talk to him again?
Oh my god, how much time do you want me...
How much do you want me to talk to you?
You're tarnished too, ain't you?
Can you see it then?
Rent a hole, me.
The guidance of grace, I mean.
I can't see it at all no more.
Makes no bloody sense anyway.
Why some no-name shithead like me should get called to the lands between.
Cruel bloody joke, you ask me.
Maybe something went tits over there.
Maybe he's been broke for a good long time.
The air tree, I'm saying.
What?
I don't know what any of that means, but okay.
Alright, let's get my horse on here.
Let's go, my little horse!
Alright.
There has to be something up ahead, right?
Please, there's so much to explore.
I'm so low.
Oh, that's a map!
There has to be a- Wait.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew you were not- Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
Alright.
Uhhhhhhhhh.
No way he knows.
That's a lobster!
Okay.
No way.
Oh my god, that's him!
Oh!
And there's so much babies!
Look at all these babies on his fucking tail!
That's the- That's the lobster.
Can't see me.
Cause he's blind!
Oh, it wasn't even a map.
Thought it was a fucking map.
Okay.
Slowly walk away.
He doesn't know.
There we go.
Dinner time!
Guys, I- I don't know.
They seem- They're sort of like- Really, really, really, really big, guys.
I-I don't know if I could make it through.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'd win this.
Wow, this area is so fucking big.
I'm like, eternally lost.
Like, there's like, no pathway or anything.
Guys, there were three of them.
If it wasn't whatever he was, then maybe.
But there was like- Oh, there's a child.
Okay, look at this.
Guys.
Fine, guys.
I'll take him.
I know you guys really wanted me to fight him.
Look.
Oh, look.
It's a family too.
Let's get that.
Oh my god!
Wait!
I thought you were a baby!
I-
Wait a minute!
Oh!
I just- I wanted- Wait!
They're doing flips and shit?!
I thought I was a baby!
Why is this baby flipping?!
Oh my god!
Oh my- Holy shit!
It's so- Holy fuck!
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I can do this.
I can do- Okay, there we go.
We killed a family.
Alright.
See, I told you guys.
I took you walk into the wrong family.
How the fuck am I supposed to know?!
It was like a fucking family of acrobatics!
I didn't know they were from the circus.
I just- I didn't know the first try.
Alright.
Let's get out of here.
I don't trust this family anymore.
Alright.
That's fine.
They can join their dead wife.
Slash mom.
Alright.
Maybe there's something over here?
What's that?
Oh, that's the tree!
Oh my god.
There's so many of them.
That's right.
I'm gonna kill Robin's family again.
What's that?
Another smithing stone.
Wait, is that- What is that over there?
The fuck is that?
Can I see that?
Why is this just in the air like that?
What is that?
Oh, wait.
Did I shoot it?
Guys, I know you guys say look at Matt, but look at where Matt-
I don't know.
I think they're like archers or some shit.
They look like archers and I don't know.
I don't trust my luck.
What Matt?
Exactly.
There's an icon?
What the fucking giant ass tree?
No, that's my icon.
I put that there.
Oh, that one?
That pillar?
Wait, have I been to this area?
I'll grab this.
What is this?
OH SHIT!
Oh, okay.
I don't know why I freaked out.
Okay.
Now I know why I freaked out.
Oh my god.
It's not a cliff.
I'm okay.
It's not a cliff, guys.
I'm so healthy.
Oh my god.
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Where do I go?
What do I... I don't...
Where?
Where, okay.
Okay, okay, here.
Okay, I don't even know where to go.
Where am I?
Where... Where the fuck did I... Oh, wait, I died next door?
Okay, nice, nice.
I died next door.
Where he fucked me up.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, it was literally right where I died.
Thank God.
Wait, where the fuck is my... Oh, there it is.
Okay, now I know.
That's right.
Wait, can I still summon?
Okay, I figured it out.
Bye.
I figured it out.
No, it's okay.
Shit.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll bait him.
Oh, that's right.
You don't know where I'm going to go.
That's okay, right?
Watch this.
Oh, no.
That's fine.
Watch this.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
I still did it.
Oh, that's right.
I got a cliff.
I have high ground.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yes, I got that, too.
Yes, I got that, too.
What did I do?
Oh, my God.
You expected to get high ground with me.
It's fine.
I'm so healthy.
Whoa.
Fine.
Yeah.
What you gonna do?
Oh, shit.
Shit.
I'm sorry.
I'm fucking sorry.
Oh my god, my controller.
Sorry, I played around with him for too long.
It's my bad.
Oh no.
Okay, I played around with my food.
Okay, okay.
I'll take it seriously this time.
I swear.
This time, I'll take this fight seriously.
Okay, because I forgot I have a death counter.
That's right.
First slice.
Oh no.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
There you go.
Okay, I figured it out.
What?
See, look at that.
I took it seriously, chat.
Look at that.
I took it seriously.
I fucking cheese my way out.
I hear the power of the rock.
That's right.
I win with the power of the rock!
The high ground!
Get anything out of here.
What the fuck?
Is this gonna be there forever?
Wait, he respawns?
Hey, what the fuck was the point of killing him?
If he just respawns.
Got the... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Why are they there?
And a whole family!
Alright.
For his weapon.
Did I got it?
I didn't even know if I got his weapon.
Or why is mine?
There's a fucking gang there!
And Toki, they live there.
You're their invader.
Oh, I got the cookbook.
Oh, hey!
Wait, I need that item.
That's a good item.
I don't know what it is, but I assume it's a good item.
Get your ass back here.
Fucking right.
Oh my god.
He's just fucking running.
Come on.
Oh my god.
He's just running.
Little bitch!
Get over here!
Ah!
Oh, where did he take me?
I'm in a new area.
Where did this guy take me?
Oh, nice.
He took me somewhere.
I don't know where.
But like, this seems like a good place to explore.
Oh, nice.
Look.
I got a hatchet.
Oh, I got a new incantation?
What's that?
Where do I equip it?
What's this?
Uh, the blood thing?
Oh, here!
Okay.
Wait, how do I equip this?
Oh, it's magic.
What the fuck?
Oh, are you following me this entire time?
Oh my god, I was in the menu.
I was like, why can't I kill him?
Oh, it's a spell.
I have to learn it.
Okay.
Oh, they've been slowly following me.
Fire ahead?
This guy?
Armant ahead.
Him?
What's around with him?
Jellyfish.
All right, go.
There you go.
That's fine.
I'll just do this.
All right, jellyfish.
Go.
Go, jellyfish!
Go!
That's fine.
You do your thing, little man.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many.
There's so many.
Oh, that's why he said liar ahead.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Die for me!
It's fine.
I can slowly, I can take them.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's ice magic.
What?
How does he hit first?
All right.
It's okay.
Oh my god, it's not okay.
It's no longer okay.
It's no longer...
Oh my god, he got me in a corner!
Okay.
Oh, I am...
I am all everywhere.
Please.
Oh, please!
I'm everywhere!
I can't see!
Oh my god, he's doing flips and shit.
All right, we got one.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's not fine.
JK, it's fine!
Oh my god, I'm leaving a message down.
There we go.
Remember the...
There's head here!
All right.
I'm gonna get the flowers out.
Okay, I have to get rid of these guys first before I grab the loot.
All right.
Things are fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, now I can grab the loot.
Oh, I don't know if that's helpful or not, but I'll take it.
I'm so good.
Like, everything just looks the same.
It all just looks the same.
Oh, hey!
Oh, there's Grace!
Nice!
All right.
I'm gonna get this Grace up real quick.
And then hope nothing comes towards me.
Yeah, I feel safe.
No, I feel safe here.
There's no way anything's gonna kill me, right?
All right.
Oh, I still don't have enough.
Oh, wait.
I can memorize the spell.
Can I do this?
Oh, I need more faith.
Okay.
I'm next to the...
Wait, what?
Am I next to a dragon?
Wait, am I not safe?
But I'm...
I'm Mother Grace!
How can I not be safe?
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm...
No, I should be fine.
I'm sitting down.
Okay, I'll be right back, guys.
I'll take a call real quick.
I notice I got a call.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
Okay, I knew it.
I knew I'd be safe.
So, I had to take a call because Dad's at the vet for his checkup.
And they were telling me what time I could pick him up.
So, I just had to, like, check my voicemail.
God, this is, like...
I swear, this...
This is, like, the most non...
I know, like, Elden Ring is, like, super...
Uh...
It's, like, different from the other Souls-like game.
And it's, like, more...
More open world.
But, like...
This is, like...
The first part was easy.
It felt like a straight line.
This one is, like, so fucking open world.
I'm so fucking lost.
I don't know where I am.
I...
Where am I?
I'm so lost.
It's...
All I see is water.
Where the fuck is the...
I've been trying to find this map for 80 years.
I wish I knew where this map is.
Maybe there's a map here.
Is that where I kill...
Is that the lobsters?
North-west?
Here?
Wait, who's trying to kill me?
Oh my god!
Don't worry.
That can't hit me, right?
Yeah, he doesn't know.
All right.
North-west.
Okay, I'll go north-west.
Surely I'll...
I'll figure it out.
Wait, what's all that?
What is that?
Are they nice?
Is this...
Oh, they're all the dunk beaters!
Oh!
Look at all these dunk beaters!
Okay, I can get that.
Let him go!
Oh!
That's cool!
It's all that free loot!
Wait, why are there dead bodies next to me?
There you go!
One more hit!
Yeah!
Where's my free loot?
Oh!
Oh, bitch!
Bitch.
That's what they were trying to do.
That's right.
Never punished.
Fucking knew it.
That's right.
You almost got me.
You almost fucking got me.
There.
Okay.
Let's go this way.
This is still northwest, right?
Why do I go up here?
There's a cliff here.
Okay.
Let me... get over here, little guy.
I will go up.
That's northwest, right?
Oh, we're out of the lake.
Oh my god.
We're finally out of the lake.
It's not just water now.
It's just grass this time.
Oh, I went past the destination?
I don't even know where I am, guys.
You think I know where destination is anymore?
I...
Guys, I don't even know where destination is.
That's the secret.
I don't even know.
I'm so fucking lost.
There's worms.
Oh, look at these little guys.
They're so pathetic.
Look at them.
Look at that.
Look at these little... Wait, they're not worms.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
It's just... They're just rocks.
Oh.
They're so pretty.
Pathetic.
Look at that.
Look at these dumb fucking rocks.
There you go.
I'll grab that.
Yeah, your friend died and you don't care.
Hey, they didn't even care their friend died.
I'll kill this sheep.
That's right.
Get over here.
I need loot.
Wait, you didn't give me any loot.
Hey, you saw that?
I'm gonna kill you too.
Get over here.
Give me your loot.
Nice.
Oh, there you go.
Hey, I needed those bones.
What the fuck?
He's just rolling.
It's so inefficient.
Running was faster.
Alright.
No boss.
Just...
Just loot.
Maybe there's something here.
Oh.
Crafting.
There's one boss.
I just...
One...
One story boss.
Where is...
I just...
I just wanna find one story boss.
Map.
Lantern like...
There's no lantern like area though.
Lantern like icon.
This?
Oh.
No.
This?
Wait, is it that?
Oh, is that a map?
Wait, where's...
That's the map, right?
Oh my god.
Where did I go?
Where did I...
Oh, I fucking...
Oh my god.
Okay, let's go back.
Let's go back.
Where am I?
What do you...
I went so far.
Holy shit.
I actually like...
Went on like...
Around the world.
I went far, far away.
I don't even know where my journey...
Ended.
I went off road.
Oh my god.
That's the lobster.
I heard many things about that man.
I was like...
I was so cold from the destination.
It wasn't even hot...
Hot...
Cold anymore.
It was like...
We're in Antarctica.
Huh?
How did I get off?
Okay.
That's the faster way.
Apparently there's a map here.
Map, map...
Wait, I walked past the map?
Is that a map?
No.
Wait, what?
I ran past the map?
I don't see no map.
A little pillar?
Oh shit, there it is.
Found the map.
Finally, I shall no longer be lost.
Oh my god.
Finally.
This is a lot different than I expected it to be.
All right.
Where's the nearest boss, guys?
We did it.
Mission accomplished.
Everything looks the same.
Boss and building?
Oh, that building?
Oh, in the academy?
All right, let's go.
Guys, I don't trust you when you... I no longer trust you when you say...
What?
When you say in the... in the dragon.
For some reason, I don't really trust you guys when you say the dragon.
Wait, I do need to kill the dragon for the academy?
I'm just a little... Wait, what's this crab doing here?
Get out of here.
Give me your loot.
Oh, I stilled his eggs.
Dragon wasn't wrong in the end?
Wait, so that's the academy.
Where's the door?
What the fuck's the door?
Wait, no.
It's here.
Yeah.
There's a gate here.
That's just a town?
What's that?
Oh, it's that thing over here.
Yeah.
Okay, I see it.
I see it.
Okay, I just gotta...
All right.
Let's go kill that dragon then.
I don't remember where the dragon is.
Wait, where did I...
Where did I leave the dragon?
I traveled so far.
I...
I traveled so fucking far.
Where the fuck did we find him?
Was he here?
Oh my god, guys.
We like...
We traveled so much.
All right, I got this.
I can kill that dragon.
Oh, there he is.
That's where all the bait was.
Okay.
I see it.
All right.
I got this.
Don't worry.
I have a friend.
Wait, I can sneak?
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm a coward.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I see him.
Wait, is this fly trying to kill me?
Okay, get out of here.
You're not part of this story.
Okay.
There you go.
Don't worry.
He's very sleepy.
You should be very, very quiet.
Being a little bitch right now.
Okay, so he's right here.
Oh, I see the body.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I got a plan.
You got this.
Goodbye.
You got this!
I believe it!
You got this jellyfish!
You already did it.
Okay, now I can go back here.
I'm safe now.
That's how it's...
He just...
He knew what he signed up for when he decided to become one of my spirit animals.
He knew what he signed up for!
He signed that contract!
He knew exactly what his purpose in life was.
Alright.
Am I under leveled?
I don't know.
I'm a little...
So worried about that.
Probably?
I feel like... Oh shit, that's a giant crab!
You know what?
I can take him.
Watch this.
Oh wait, that crab is easy.
Watch that.
Look at him.
He's actually such a little baby!
Look at this baby crab!
That's fucking right!
I knew he was a baby!
That's right.
I only kill the babies.
In game.
In Elden Ring.
Wait, this guy died to a baby?
Wait, no.
I think he died to all that.
Wait, I need to make sure he died to whatever all those shit is.
Where's the...
Where do I go next?
Okay.
I just followed all the way here?
Yeah, I feel like I should avoid those.
I'm trying to like...
Oh my god, how am I lost?
I have a map!
Don't worry.
We'll find our first boss somewhere.
I have more items.
Dude!
Oh, it's Golden Seed!
Oh, it's here.
Okay, I figured it out.
I see the area.
Oh, wait.
Did I like, avoid them?
No, I can take him.
I believe.
I've...
I have a special weapon.
This is my special weapon.
My special weapon.
Alright, come over here.
Oh my god, nice.
Friendly fire.
Nice!
Oh, thank god!
You go!
Jellyfish!
I believe!
Oh my god.
It's fine.
He's tanking it all.
Yippee!
I told you I have a special weapon.
Okay, I gotta get him out of the way.
And then also hit him too.
That's right.
Shitty bodyguard.
Right there.
Damn, should have protected your team better.
We did...
Wait, there's loot?
Did he have loot?
I didn't see.
Holy fuck!
Oh my god, he's angry.
Oh, they have loot!
He's like, let me at him!
Do not do the academy, not only...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I was reading!
Whoa!
Wait, then what do I do?
If I don't do the academy, what do I do?
I'm so lost!
What do I have if I don't do the academy?
Okay.
Ignore it.
My energy is so low.
Don't listen to that guy.
Oh no.
My dragoons are fighting now.
Door.
Bad message!
No door?
What the fuck are you talking about?
Precious item ahead?
Oh, I already killed at that.
The one guys are fighting.
Oh yeah, there's an item here.
Oh, it was just arrows.
Oh, fuck!
That combo!
No!
Oh, he's here.
Oh, there he is.
Nice.
Alright.
My buddy and I.
Okay, we gotta quit.
Oh, butterflies.
Let me kill these butterflies real quick.
Oh my god!
I know that guy from Night Reign!
I know him!
He was in Night Reign!
Okay.
Yeah, I think we're gonna start running.
Don't get one.
Don't eat.
It will be fine.
Mostly.
Alright, goodbye.
I believe in you, jellyfish.
I believe in you!
Hey guys!
Let's go!
No!
Oh, I think my friend died.
It's okay.
He'll be back.
Nice.
See you guys?
We made it.
Look at that.
See?
Running away from your problems is the right move.
Don't listen to your therapist.
But also, maybe listen to your therapist.
Oh, nice.
Okay, add charge.
Yay!
Okay, but...
I'm almost too leveled up.
Alright, that has to be a boss.
That is so boss-like.
That has to be a boss.
Alright, we could kill one guy.
Thanks, Zookie.
I now have crippling...
Oh.
It's not?
But there's so many bloodstains.
So many people died.
Does say visions of good fortune are ahead.
Oh, nice.
I got a map.
Seek west, but be wary of a dragon.
Seek dra...
Oh wait, I already did that.
I did it!
I got the dragon.
A foot.
Thank you.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my god, I'm alive.
Merchant ahead.
Ooh!
Nice.
Likely blood loss.
Don't worry.
I think my jellyfish is still fighting that dragon to this day.
I think he...
I'm pretty sure he won, guys.
Up here?
Therefore order required ahead.
Wait, where did the merchant go?
No horseback battle ahead.
What's over here?
Yeah, this looks like a PvP spot.
Yeah, this does look like one.
Examine seal?
Was I just here?
Oh.
Wait, no, this is new.
Yeah, I've never been here.
Yeah, this is a new spot.
I've never been here before.
Whoops.
Forgot to charge my phone.
Oopsie.
There you go.
Nice charge.
Oh!
Nice.
New spot.
I'm out on the back door.
Heard is a little more exciting.
Alright.
Okay, so we go forward to the academy.
Okay, no horseback riding.
Alright.
Up I go!
Yeah!
No!
I can't put it on the emplivator!
What's the point?
Oh, where am I?
Oh, there's the academy.
Oh, is this where all the magic students are?
Is this the magic?
The...
The fucking teacher level?
That I always see like...
People...
Like, clips of?
Ah, man.
This is where all the fucking nerds live.
Stupid nerds.
God damn it.
Fucking nerds.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I got one of the nerds.
That's fucking right!
What you gonna do now, nerd?
That's right!
I don't even recharge my stamina!
Wait, you can say that?
That bird...
Be wary up?
Oh, wait.
What's up above...
What's ahead?
Alright.
Let's put my message down.
Ah!
Let's see.
Is there a nerd?
Ha ha ha ha!
Sinner!
That's it.
Ah ha!
Sinner!
He he he he!
Wasn't there a thing where like...
Uh...
People who are like...
Extra Christian can't read any books about magic because like...
You get sent to hell?
Because like...
Because magic is like...
The source...
Like the power of the devil.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
That's right!
Look at all these sinners!
You're all going to hell!
That's fucking right!
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
Wait, I can't send jellyfish?
Wait, what's the point if I...
Holy shit!
Oh!
Okay, he tripped and fell.
Oh my god, they don't have to use stairs.
Thank god.
Okay, it's not a summon area.
Why they never summon area when I need him?
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Get this nerd out of here.
I like how they...
I like how they can trip on stairs.
Like...
That brings me joy.
What?
Oh, there we go.
I needed this.
Alright.
Nice.
Do I know?
Oh, I almost do.
I can just fight them here.
It's true.
The instant they...
The moment they look at a book about magic, they go straight to hell.
Hello?
Hey.
Okay, I don't have...
Okay, the only...
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I just wanted more...
Oh, thank you for the message was a praise.
Thank...
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
The airport, thank you for the super chat.
I really...
Thanks guys.
Thank you for the message.
I was gonna leave.
I don't wanna fight...
I don't wanna fight those guys.
Those guys are a little...
A little too freaky for me.
I'm right outside.
What?
Why am I outside?
Be wary of the right...
Oh, there he is.
Oh, and he still gets me.
It's fine.
Oh, I should be...
Almost close too.
I almost have a level up.
Alright guys.
What do I level up?
Wait, that's the entrance to the school?
I thought that...
Am I...
I thought...
Oh wait.
Actual good message.
I have enough.
Figure?
Alright.
Level up.
We have...
Figure.
Alright.
So I was going the right way.
I'll kill him again.
I know you're here.
Come on.
Get over here.
I know you're here.
Oh, fuck!
I...
He got me again.
I don't know how.
How does he keep doing it?
Jesus.
Oh, he got me.
No!
Oh wait.
I don't...
Joke's on you!
I don't use magic!
Cause I ain't no pussy!
That's okay, right.
Joke's on you!
Maybe I'll start using magic here though.
Nice.
What the fuck?
He just watched his friend die.
Did not care.
Secret passage ahead?
Yeah?
Fucker.
You fucker.
You fucker!
No!
There was no secret message!
My god.
No.
No, it's okay.
I don't have magic.
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter if I don't have magic!
It's fine.
I can...
That's good.
I just wanted more...
More souls.
It's okay.
It got me.
It actually got me.
I...
Alright.
Is there...
Where's the word for true?
Do it.
Alright.
Wait.
There is actually a secret passage?
Swear to god.
Oh my god.
Wait.
He wasn't lying?
Oh.
Okay.
I'm glad that he like...
It was like...
Oh wait.
Hey there.
It's like those hikers.
You know, like you bump into another hiker.
And you're like, hey.
Nice hike we're having, aren't we?
It's the type of hiker.
It's like, oh yeah.
We're having a night.
On your right.
There's no way.
I don't believe it.
Okay.
There's no blood though.
Turkey.
You can trust it.
My god.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna make this jump.
No blood.
No light.
Jump for the beam.
Alright.
Where do I...
Okay.
I'm looking.
Where is it?
I'm looking at it.
Where the fuck is it?
Where is it?
I'm looking.
Right.
It's down there.
Turkey.
Look down.
Alright.
I'm gonna look down.
Where is it?
It's invisible.
There's an invisible wall, turkey.
Oh, hey.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's a...
Oh.
It teleports you.
Don't worry.
I swear to God.
I... I swear to God.
If I... if I go there and I swear...
Cuz you are tempting me right now.
I am actually... cuz no bloodstains.
There's no bloodstains.
It's safe to us.
Oh my God.
I don't trust you.
I don't trust any of you.
You almost got me.
I... I thought about it.
I thought about it.
It was in my head.
It was...
I... I thought about it.
It was right there.
So it was this way?
Wait, do I go...
You were... I was... I was this close!
I...
Wait.
Left side or right side chat?
Bridge or not bridge?
Cuz I went in the secret path.
Oh, that's where I was?
Here?
Oh, not the bridge.
Okay.
I was this close.
I almost did it.
I really was so close.
I thought about it.
Okay, let's get him out.
I was like...
Oh my God!
What the fuck he's like?
I want in too!
Nice.
Oh.
Let's drop off here?
Alright.
So many.
Oh my God!
Okay, okay.
Okay, let me think about this.
I'll kill him first.
The only thing I worry about is I accidentally fall off.
That's the one thing.
Let's grab...
Where do I go?
Where do I go if I just grab and go...
Where?
Where do I go?
Okay, he's too busy.
Oh my God!
I didn't wanna...
Okay, that's fine.
That's also fine.
That's...
Oh nice!
Oh!
And he's the best armor?
Alright.
Let's equip.
Wait, is it?
Oh, it is.
Oh my God!
It's like so much better.
Alright.
Oh!
I am looking pretty handsome right now!
Ladies!
What at a time!
Behold!
Okay.
Where is it?
Look at Mia!
Behold!
Lover!
Look at me!
I'm your knight in shining armor!
That is lover material right there!
Behold!
Lover!
HEHEHEHEHEHEHEHEHEHE Item ahead!
Ooh!
Item ahead!
Oh hey!
Where's the item?
Oh!
it's a golden room!
Oh that's good!
Hubba hubba!
Look at me!
And ladies!
Look at the worst place for our message!
What do you mean?
That's the perfect place for our message!
Oh, there's the item.
Oh, magic grease.
Oh, hey.
That's right.
Look at you slowly rise up from the grave.
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god, there's so many dogs!
There's so many dogs!
Oh
my god, oh my god, oh my god,
oh my god, there's so many dogs!
Get me out of here!
It's just dogs!
Oh my god,
please.
Oh my god, I lived.
I lived.
Influencer built!
Read Supreme!
Save!
Oh my god!
Save because I'm a content creator!
Let's go!
Start your content creation journey today!
That's like crazy.
I don't know how.
That's crazy.
I should be dead.
How do I get... It's easy.
Start streaming, get thousands of people to watch you, and then you too can beat Elden Ring with this build.
Chat, don't let Turki's new trip distract you from the fact that... Not yet!
You don't know that!
Just you wait.
This is who you bullied in high school.
Oh, he fell down.
Wait, this is the guy I was like...
I was trying to beat... Oh my god, this is bullshit.
I literally can't do a combo because he's stuck against the wall.
Okay.
Jesus, how is he faster?
He's fine.
Oh wait, he stopped moving.
He's tired.
He's so tired.
Behind.
Item ahead.
Oh nice, another golden rune.
Oh my god.
I'm not okay right now.
My guy is so fucked up.
I'm so fucked up.
If only I had a giant butthole.
Where the fuck are the...
Graces?
I need a grace like right now.
I don't like this.
Oh, I don't like it.
I don't know where all the grace is.
But I like this.
Oh, I definitely don't like this.
Oh my god.
I can never summon anything.
Oh my god!
Jesus!
Oh!
I'm running.
I don't think I live this.
I don't think I live this, guys.
Oh, I can't reach it!
Aha, JK.
Yes, I can.
Aha!
Wait, I think I can kill him by high ground.
Wait, I think I can high ground abuse him.
Oh!
Oh my god!
He does!
Oh,
you freeze!
Goodbye.
Goodbye, goodbye.
I'm not a coward, guys!
Okay,
it's a tactical retreat.
It's a tactical retreat, guys.
Oh my god!
I'm okay.
I'm safe.
I'm so safe.
I feel so safe.
Oh my god.
That's right.
Get backstabbed.
I got bullied, so I bully you.
Behold.
God.
Oh.
I'm not gonna make that.
I continue the cycle.
Time for left?
Oh, okay.
I'll get that later.
Oh, there's a grace here.
Nice.
Oh, thank god.
I found a grace.
Thank fucking god.
Alright, I wanna get that item.
Like, right here.
Okay, but there's a...
There's an item right here, though.
Yeah!
I don't know what that is, but I'm grabbing it.
Oh, hey.
Yeah, that's right.
I've killed your friend.
This makes me feel good about myself.
Yeah, I feel stronger.
I feel like the bigger man.
That's right.
No down ahead.
Who said go down?
No down.
You're like, go down.
No down ahead.
Alright, let's go this way.
Try running.
Oh!
Okay, now try running.
Weeeee!
That's fine.
I just need to...
Okay, I'll follow this.
Open.
No!
Open!
I can't open from...
No!
Okay.
Alright.
This way.
Okay, now go up.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
And then I heal.
Okay, and then...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
I dodged everything.
Let's go.
There we go.
Oh, it's a wolf.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh!
Hey.
Oh, hey!
Hey, buddy.
Jesus Christ!
Oh!
Okay.
I was not ready.
I was not ready for that.
This is the nerd I put in the locker.
Revenge for the dogs.
Alright.
No, I got this.
I was, like, trying to figure out what the fuck was going on, and then he killed me.
My brain was, like, ten seconds behind.
Guys, it's not my fault!
My mind was ten seconds behind from what was actually happening.
That was a warm-up round.
Alright, here we go.
For real this time.
Okay, and then I can do this.
Come here, my jellyfish!
Oh!
I said, come here!
What the fuck?!
Why is he still trying to kill me?!
Oh my god, jellyfish!
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
He's distracted.
Oh my- Not anymore!
Oh my god, please.
Please, he's so fast.
It's, like, really fucked up because he's, like, going for him, running away from me, and then running towards me, and I'm- Every time.
Please!
Oh my god, you fucker!
He has no chance.
He goes back and- Okay, my jellyfish- My jellyfish is, like, maybe low-key fucking me up.
I-
My jellyfish is- My jellyfish is, like, fucking up the playstyle.
Okay, no.
I promise- I promise myself, I'll take him to endgame.
Nobody believed in you, jellyfish, but me.
Even though I told you that you're fucking me up.
Nobody believed in you, but me.
I believe in you, jellyfish.
Even though you're fucking up this run for me.
Okay.
I- Oh my god, that's me.
Wow!
Please, I just- Let me shoot you!
Please!
Oh my god, this stupid knife.
Okay.
I- That hits me!
Stop jumping!
Oh my god, this fucker!
This fucker!
Oh my god, my jellyfish is dead.
I don't know what he did, but he's dead.
Okay.
Oh my god, I thought he was gonna do something else.
That's my bad.
That's my fucking bad for thinking that.
That's- Oh my god, I hate your moves!
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm not downloading his moves.
I'm not downloading his moves right now!
Ah!
His rage baby man is working!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
You fucker.
I hate you.
I wanna know where your family lives.
Where does your wife live?
Fix
me!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Influencer build is actually coming in clutch right now.
Oh my god!
Please!
Jesus!
I hate this combo!
What the fuck was
that?!
Oh, I used up everything.
It's fine.
I still have my Influencer build.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Stupid back and forth.
Oh my god.
He has a third strike.
You strike a third time?
Okay.
I hate you.
I
can't hit you three times!
You're such a fucker!
You're actually such a whore!
Oh my god.
If I wasn't a content creator, I'd be dead ten times already.
I...
Oh!
I'm keeping so greedy!
I'm...
No!
Oh!
That's right!
You should've started streaming, little one!
If you started streaming, dog, you would've lived!
That's right!
Get content created!
After 30 heals!
I did...
I did not deserve that win!
I 100% did not deserve it!
But I'll take it!
I...
I found ten health bars!
Finally!
You know those bosses?
Where...
I can finally feel like an actual boss!
I...
I can finally play like a fucking actual boss fight!
I am the boss fight in the end!
That's me!
I'm the fucking boss fight!
That they have to deal with!
I...
I can...
I am...
Alright!
What do we upgrade guys?
I...
I knew...
Dexterity?
Okay!
We can upgrade two things!
How many...
How man...
How many phases does she have?
It's time...
Is it time...
to pivot...
To big heavy hangover!
Yeah, I think it was a super chat!
Thank you!
Two with dexterity?
No dog was fighting all the fans.
It was like... it was 1v a thousand.
Alright.
Put two on dexterity.
Oh, we did it guys.
I'm crazy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not locked in here with you.
You're locked in here with me.
Alright.
What would be streaming?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I got one.
Where is it?
Still no parrying.
No parrying.
Me, thank you for the 10 gift of shoes.
Thank you, thank you.
Props, thank you for the super chat.
You can go back to the big water meal.
Go to the bottom.
Go eat... get eaten by the Iron Man.
There is a fun secret there.
I'll do it...
...before I end stream.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guess I'll go forward?
Go to that big scary castle over there?
Oh, guess I can.
Oh, wait, no, I can.
It is not fun.
Oh, I think it was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah, I got a key.
Get these guys out of here.
He's like, hey.
Why'd you kill him?
Oh, wait.
You got this, jellyfish.
I believe in you.
Oh, my God.
I believe in him.
That guy almost baited me.
Holy shit.
I do no damage.
I do no damage, guys.
I do...
Wait a minute.
I don't do any damage.
How do I kill him if I don't do damage?
Holy shit.
Okay, I leave.
No, no.
You got this.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, hey, guys.
Okay,
let me...
Let me just go over here.
I'm going to leave now.
Toki, it's half health.
You can do this.
Okay, wait.
Wait, I can?
You guys really believe in me?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait, I'm inside him!
How the fuck did he get me?
I jumped inside.
I didn't even know I got inside.
All right, I'm leaving.
Oh, shit!
Okay, now I'm leaving.
Okay, I'm leaving.
For real now.
Wait, he seems like a fun guy.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Not friendly.
Not friendly!
Okay, to be fair, I thought we were friends.
Because I didn't see anything.
I thought we were friends.
I legitimately thought we were going to be best of friends.
Goodness.
All right.
No way this magic hits there.
Oh!
There was a way, guys.
There was indeed a way.
There was a way.
Oh my god.
No!
He one-shot me!
Oh my god!
It actually one-shot me.
Get her next.
I didn't think it would happen.
I don't even know where I am.
Oh, it's swift.
Okay, I know where I died.
What?
The nerds fight back.
Who showed these nerds how to fight?
Okay, I figured it out though.
All right.
They saw me.
They're slowly wandering over.
Wait, they all saw me.
Wait a minute.
How did you all saw me?
What's the boss now?
Oh my god.
Wait, how did he see me?
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
I just gotta kill him.
That's okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine getting killed by a nerd.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He just slowly backed away!
That's cheating!
Oh my god.
He just slowly backed away!
Oh.
Yeah.
Right, nerd.
That's right!
Okay, now I can lose- loot this.
All right, there's the jar.
Oh, I got another crackpot.
Nice.
Take that, nerd.
That's fucking right.
Did it.
I don't know how, but I did it.
I don't fucking...
Push it.
Oh, shit!
I got baited.
I got baited by the nerds again.
I fucking...
Okay, that's it.
I'm taking my anger out on you.
Continue the cycle.
And that's fine.
That's not fine.
Okay.
Okay, I...
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me figure out what to do.
Okay.
I didn't figure it out, guys.
All right, take this.
You got...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Do I have arrows?
I don't think I have any arrows.
Let me check.
Oh, I do.
Oh, my God.
I don't...
Never mind.
I don't think it's worth it.
Okay, they're...
Oh, my God.
They're just spamming me.
That's cheating.
Okay, let me...
Let me get my...
Oh, my God.
Okay, I got this.
I need the element of surprise.
All right.
I figured this out.
I also don't remember how to use my bow.
All right.
I know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Wait.
Okay.
They're getting involved, though.
They shouldn't be.
Give me a sec.
Okay, now.
Now I know what to do.
No, I have arrows.
Look at this.
See?
Oh, wait.
I don't.
Wait.
No, see?
I do.
Oh, wait.
I don't.
Never mind.
It's time.
Three.
Two.
Okay.
Three.
Two.
One.
Let's go.
What you see?
It wasn't that way.
Guys, we gotta reset this.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Oh, there was?
I had to jump the... Okay, gotta reset.
I wasn't paying attention because I was panicking.
I don't know if that was noticeable, guys.
I...
I don't know if it was noticeable, but I may have been panicking.
I didn't see the other pathway.
But let me get rid of these guys first before I do anything.
Yeah, it was not that noticeable, right?
It wasn't, right?
I didn't think so.
Okay, I can do this again.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's right here.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, dang!
Okay.
Bye.
We did it.
Okay, we figured it out.
And now I can open this door.
There we go.
That's right.
No time to use your magic now, nerd.
That's fucking right!
Aha!
I beat the nerds at their own game.
Wait.
This is not the path?
Wait a minute.
Then why the fuck did I go here?
Oh, wait.
There's another path here.
Oh, is it parkour time?
Parkour.
I got this.
Watch this.
Oh, he did say try jumping.
Item ahead?
Why is it always something incredible?
Parkour.
Time to do a flip.
Alright.
Up I go.
I'm not afraid of these guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, where's the arrow guy?
Where did he go?
He like... What?
Okay.
How the fuck does that hit me?
He's just slowly backing in the corner.
What the fuck is he doing?
Oh my god.
Is that... Am I gonna be okay?
Okay?
Guys, you think I'm gonna live?
Bro, it's just... Bro, I think that hit the heart.
It looks like a heart.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I almost jumped off.
I actually almost jumped off.
I wanted it to look cool.
I almost jumped off.
There's no way.
I don't fucking believe you.
I... It's just...
Not here?
Wait, it is the right jump?
I believe.
Right on my head.
Oh, right here.
Oh, nice.
More golden runes.
I need those.
Okay.
There's a ladder, you fuckers.
I was so ready.
I...
I was ready to do it.
I was gonna do it.
I...
I was actually...
I was just gonna do it.
I wasn't gonna question anything.
Oh, him.
Oh, you...
I didn't see you, huh?
Oh my god.
It's you.
It's one of these guys.
That's right.
What?
Oh my god.
He baited me.
He actually baited me.
He's...
I don't have a summon.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Fucking right.
Get in this corner.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Get out here.
You're not bleeding me.
Okay, that shouldn't hit me.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Wait, does your mana expire?
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, the fuck did he have so much mana?
Here we go this way.
Never.
That's the funny part, Doki.
They never expire.
Can't mute your butt.
All right.
Let's do this here.
Why did so many people die here, though?
He's got a book.
He reads, Doki.
What the fuck?
I don't feel like it is that way.
Must be another way.
Is it really across those roofs?
It's like, if only I had a ladder.
Try it down.
And then...
And then what?
Okay.
How did all these people die?
Oh.
That makes sense.
That is...
Yes.
Okay.
Hello.
First.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he's bugging out.
He's actually glitching out right now.
Oh my god, like, he's just vibrating.
He's like, stuck on the roof.
What does he mean, like?
First off, left?
Like, do I drop here?
What does he mean, left side?
Huh?
So lonely.
Lonely.
Mr. Lonely.
I have no body.
Come on.
I got this this way.
Oh, wait.
There is an item here.
Oh, I got a sword.
I got a sword key.
Okay, but what if I jump there?
No, don't do it.
Don't let the intrusive thoughts win.
Don't let them win, doki.
There's a ladder here.
What's over here?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, hey, there's an item.
There's...
Oh my god, the crabs are eating him.
What if I kill one of your friends?
Oh, I get nothing out of it.
Never mind.
Okay, back up.
Now I go back up.
It's okay.
That other friend was, like, the third wheel.
Now they can...
It was the third wheel.
That couple's gonna thank me.
Now they can get freaky.
Did I jump through this room?
I don't know.
There's, like, guys here.
I'm gonna do it.
I don't know where else to go.
I don't think he heard me.
Guys, he heard me.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
It was a trap!
What's he gonna do now?
Aha, I'm on the other side.
Wait, he's following me.
Aha, what you gonna do now?
Aha, oh shit!
Oh shit, haha!
Can't catch me!
Oh shit, maybe he can.
Aha, the AI's confused now!
Oh wait, there's an item over here.
Oh nice!
Haha, they don't know what to do.
Oh no, they split up.
Wait.
That's not good.
Wait, where do I go?
Oh my god, what the fuck was that?!
I'm so sick.
Can't catch me.
Watch this.
That's right.
Where am I?
I don't know.
Where did I...
Drop Chandelier!
There was a right doll!
I don't even know where I am!
Where did I go?
Who's that guy?
Oh, he does... Oh, he... Oh my god!
He definitely does not look friendly!
Oh!
No!
Oh my god!
I'm dead.
Where am I?
I don't want to do this all over here.
No!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, I know where to go now.
No, I can get those runes again.
Guys, I can get it.
Don't worry.
I believe.
You just gotta believe, guys.
I realized I didn't have to go this way.
But it's too late.
I'm in too deep.
Ow!
It's fine.
I believe.
It feels like 20 years since I was here.
But I remember.
Wait, I don't remember.
Wait.
Oh, I remember!
JK!
Oh my god!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine!
It's... I'm so healthy.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
My ass is okay.
It's just my ass.
It's extra cushioned.
Don't worry.
My ass is like extremely cushioned for this.
It's okay.
It was trained for this one moment.
I'm thick as hell.
Alright, it's here.
Here.
Okay, next time I won't, uh...
I will not, like, engage in the... in the... in that.
Where did I drop last time?
Here, right?
Oh, hey!
There's an item here.
Wait, where did I drop?
Oh my god!
I got that item.
Okay, guys.
I need to get my other stuff first.
It's gonna be worth it.
Hello, sir.
Oh my god.
Wait, I...
My soul is literally right there.
No!
I forgot what color it was.
I...
Now I have to...
I ran past it.
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait, that's not my...
Wait a minute.
I just ran past my soul.
I forgot.
I forgot what it looked like.
Guys, I actually forgot what it looked like.
Oh my god.
I was like, wait a minute.
Where those my souls over there?
I...
That's why I turned around.
I was like, oh shit.
Wait, I think that's the right soul back there.
I...
Okay.
Now I have nothing.
Oh my god.
It dodges.
Now I have nothing to lose.
Okay, it's fine.
I have nothing to lose now.
Guys, I have nothing to lose.
Are you sure you can't believe it?
Because I can.
That seems like something I do.
Alright.
I have no pressure anymore.
No more pressure.
Alright, here we go.
I was going to say, how did you not believe it?
I fucking think that was the first thing I do.
That was the first thing I think I do.
And then here.
Back at it again.
Now I have no fear.
Can't fear something I don't have.
Okay, now I know which chandelier to jump on.
Guys.
I know now.
There you go.
There's the chandelier.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, now where the...
Do I go down here?
Where the fuck do I go after that?
Oh shit.
I guess I'll go outside.
I feel safer.
Oh!
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, hey.
Dog ahead.
Hey, why are you...
Oh shit!
You fight back?
Okay, nice.
Pre-loot.
First off, friend.
But item.
It's true, though.
It's true.
He has item.
It's friend-shaped.
But item.
Again, head.
You wary of, right?
Oh, that's the crab.
Item.
What the fuck?
It's fucking right.
Oh my!
Okay, that's it.
That's it.
I'm taking you outside.
Your friend can't help you now.
Alright.
Let's make sure we kill everything around here.
Oh, nice.
I got crystal.
Oh my god.
Did I actually have to go to that guy?
Get out of here.
What is it, ladder?
I don't think I saw that.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I see it.
Alright.
Kick ladder.
Whoa!
There we go.
Okay.
Do I actually have to fucking kill that guy?
There's a crossbow guy?
Where the fuck is he?
If you want to, I don't.
He like, he like fucked me up.
I don't, guys.
He really fucked me up, guys.
He was really scary.
Wait, then where do I go?
Wait, I...
What the fuck?
They clapped the stairs?
I didn't get up here!
Ah!
They both of them get up here!
Excuse me?
Oh my god.
I hate you.
They can collapse!
Who gave them thumbs?
I won't have that.
Anything here?
No.
I'm like, eternally lost.
They're like...
Beware of ambush.
Ladder, ladder.
That crossbow guy?
That guy?
Why?
Him?
Boys, you're gonna fuck me up!
Beat him.
Okay.
He's alone now.
Kadoki, it's just one guy.
Okay, you're right.
You're so right.
You're so right!
Oh, I bleed him!
That's right!
Fight!
I'm a boss!
Oh, my god.
Oh, my g... Oh, just don't get shot.
Thank you for telling me that.
Thank you.
Hey, guys.
Guys, I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Oh, man.
Thanks, guys.
I didn't know he could do that!
I... Where am I in this area?
Oh, I'm here.
Okay.
Like, was it here?
Just don't get shot.
Alright.
I was here, right?
Yeah, it was.
And then... Okay, there's the ladder.
I'm going for the ladder.
I'm faster than this.
Oh, my... Oh, my... Oh,
my...
Oh, my... I wasn't... I wasn't... I wasn't... Oh, my god.
Please.
Please, I'm... Please.
Please I don't know why.
I don't know why.
Okay.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We got one.
We got two.
Oh, hey, my zero souls.
Let's go.
I don't know why I thought I was faster.
I don't know, guys.
I just had such high hopes.
I am not able to climb the ladder.
Who's the nerd now?
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The real G.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm faster than them.
Brod, who was slower?
I don't know.
I just thought, I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe I was for once.
Okay.
That's fine.
I just thought maybe luck was on my side.
Oh my god.
Okay.
My range was not it.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
That's fine.
Prospect.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I like to pay to see Doki because I run back and try to explode.
Dang.
All right.
Okay.
Now, now that I know how it works.
Now that I know.
All right.
That's it.
Oh!
Okay.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Oh!
Get dodged!
Oh shit!
That's fine.
Oh, that's wrecking blitz!
Yeah!
I figured it out.
Guys, I figured it out.
I actually figured it out.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Wait, that's it?
Wait.
I did this for no reason?
Wait a minute.
Guys!
You took me to a fucking detour!
Why did you take me to a...
Oh my god.
You got the staff?
I'm not even a nerd!
Oh my god.
I don't even use magic!
The staff was the cult.
Oh, I can memorize sorcery?
You must have a staff.
Oh, wow.
I wish...
I wish that was helpful.
The shortest way is the detour.
The staff...
Wow!
I wish I was...
I wish I could use it!
Oh, now you can invest in arcane.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I...
Okay, now for the real path.
The wolf room?
Is this the wolf room?
No.
This was not the wolf room.
Have I been going the wrong way this entire time?
Let's check every crevice and every corner.
Get good, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes!
You made me parkour for no reason!
Hey, buddy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
At least you have a cool stick.
You got the staff.
Head right!
I went left!
And it was right all...
Oh my god.
I head left and it was right...
Don't tell me I was supposed to go down here.
I...
Oh my god.
I went all the way there.
I think I wasn't paying attention.
Guys, I don't think...
Oh!
How did I live that?
Oh my god.
I accidentally healed because I was scared.
I...
I faced her.
Okay.
Try parrying.
Okay, guys.
We are now.
Let's go ahead.
Oh my god.
He's running at me, isn't he?
He's...
Oh my god!
I...
Step in!
I saw him running at me in the fucking distance.
Oh my god.
Wait, he's me.
Oh, I'm trying to...
He said jump attack!
I'm trying to do the jump attack!
Holy fuck!
Goodbye.
Oh...
He doesn't let me...
He doesn't let me leave.
He doesn't let me be.
He doesn't...
Ah!
Okay.
Fight back!
Oh my god!
I'm trying!
Please, I'm actually trying to fight back.
He's me, but he's so much cooler.
He's me, but he's so much cooler, guys.
He's also faster?!
Oh my god.
You can never beat him.
That's fair!
Why is he so much faster?!
Oh my god, he didn't parry that.
That's right.
That's right, you didn't parry that.
He can heal?!
Wait!
That's illegal!
Wait a minute!
And he uses magic!
Pick a struggle!
They're passing because they got...
The better that he has everything that's not...
He does everything that you don't do, Doki.
He's so cool!
And with that, you reached the same number of deaths as last stream, Doki.
Congrats!
Thank you with the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's the part of Doki.
Thank you, Reed and Parry.
Thank you with the super chat, Alan.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, who is he?!
I didn't know they made Doki burn too.
Why is he... Why is... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
I'm such a mess now!
He's that guy.
I can't...
He fucked me up, guys.
I'm so scared.
He's so much better than me, and I'm so scared.
Hehehehe.
Like, why is he so fast?!
No!
AHHHHH!
Why are you so much...
Wait, he breathes!
Does Doki actually breathes?
Get parried.
You've got better...
Get fucking parried.
Oh my god, he's you if you know how to parry, Toki.
Oh my god.
I tried to jump attack, but he just fucks me up.
Okay.
I just gotta go this way.
Okay, I should make it before the rocket's summoned, right?
Okay, I got it.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah.
Guys, I don't know.
Oh my god, not again.
Not again.
Guys, that's fucking...
Oh, no!
I'm bad!
I'm sorry, no!
Oh my god.
Is that the infamous Toko bird?
Fatty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got too confident.
Oh my god.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I can beat a Toko bird.
I can beat her.
She'll never be as good as the original.
I got this.
She can never be better than the original Toki bird.
Okay.
You figured out how to parry?
No.
Even better.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, that's fucking right.
Oh fuck!
Oh my god.
He thought...
He thought I was gonna hit that, but I didn't!
Watch this.
Oh shit, he's doing...
He's copying me!
That's illegal!
Oh!
Oh, and you're also gonna heal too?
You fucker!
Oh my god, that's strange.
Bro!
He's copying me!
He's actually fucking...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna kill him.
I...
He ran you like...
He got anti-aired now.
He fucking anti-aired me!
That whore!
Oh!
When he has the staff, he can't parry?
Okay, I didn't know that.
Okay, now that I know.
Magic seems pretty cool now, does it?
No!
You can't convince me!
I just need more gains!
That's it!
That's it, guys!
I'm just lacking more...
I just need more gains!
And then I can beat up this nerd.
No, they can never be better than the original...
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god!
He still hits me!
What the fuck?
How does he still hit me?
Oh my god!
I'm trying to jump!
Okay,
nice.
Nice.
Okay.
What?
Oh my god!
The range!
Yeah.
Yes!
That's right!
My turn!
That's fucking right!
It's my turn!
Bitch!
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
Fucker.
Oh my god, you're such a fucker.
You're such a whore.
You're actually such a whore.
He's just slowly walking up to me.
Okay.
I'm not doing so well.
Nice.
Stop!
You're such a bitch!
Don't go burn!
Oh my god.
You're actually such a bitch.
You're such a bitch!
I let you heal!
That's fucking right!
You're never better than the original!
You'll never be better than me!
You're just a copy!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
You're just a copy of an- You're an inferior version of the original.
Oh my god!
Love your time!
Oh, where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Weak flow.
And then strong flow.
Didn't expect strong flow.
Oh, there was a shortcut?
Okay.
Let me go back.
Bro, god.
That's right!
I DMCA'd him!
That's fucking right!
And I'll do it again!
Three strikes and you're out!
Alright.
Sorry I had to blow my nose.
Got too lazy to mute myself after that.
Apparently there's- Is there like- Shortcut here?
Is it here?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
That's so- Oh my god!
He hit me back the staircase.
Let's get rid of these guys first.
Wait.
Ahead?
That Goko Brint would mute.
Wait.
Where's the shortcut?
Is it up top?
You're left by the ball?
Yeah?
Oh.
Jump the ledge.
Okay.
No.
Go straight?
Oh.
Okay.
I'm so confused.
I feel like- One chat's telling the lie.
The other is telling the truth.
Oh there it is.
Nevermind.
Trick cut!
What's him?
It's this area.
It's that fucking door.
It's-
It's that fucking area.
Okay.
What's here then?
You wary of fruit?
Oh.
One...
Two...
Alright.
That's more than enough.
Time to leave.
I mean...
You cute.
Yeah.
Sesame.
Yeah!
So it is here.
Oh.
How is that shortcut?
Wait, what's this?
First off, done.
Okay.
Okay?
Touch it?
Oh.
Don't touch it?
I won't touch it.
Why should I level first?
Where the fuck is my level up area?
Is there like a grace anywhere?
I don't even know where- Oh my god, there has to be a grace somewhere.
I have to go back?
Are you- Okay.
No, it should be fine.
I should be fine.
I got this.
I don't- Wait.
Where was that area?
Is it here?
Where was that part?
It was here.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'll level up.
I think I have enough, right?
Okay.
Okay, the ball run was not that bad.
The ball- Oh wait, I don't have enough.
Fuck!
I don't have enough for the level up.
Okay, I need to- a thousand.
God damn it.
Okay.
But if I die here...
Okay, I got it.
I know what to do.
Okay.
I can kill some babies.
Oh my god, I have runes.
I forgot I carried so many.
I found so many runes.
I was just keeping collection.
Alright, where is my runes?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, that should be enough.
That's like 6k.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Level up.
Okay, what do we level up, guys?
What do we level up?
HP or dexterity?
Vigor or dexterity, guys?
Vigor?
Okay.
We'll do dexterity next.
Alright.
Now it's time to run.
Okay, we're in the arcane soon.
Alright.
Don't worry.
First we go this way.
Oh wait, I should upgrade my weapon as well.
You're right.
I haven't upgraded my weapon in a while.
God, it's so far.
It's so far.
Alright, where is that guy?
Oh, legitimately when I first boot up this game, I thought I booted up Night Ring.
It's been that long.
I was just like...
I accidentally...
I accidentally played like Night Ring.
Alright.
Wait, I don't have enough money.
Oh wait, I do.
I do.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Do another...
I'm gonna do another rune.
One rune!
Alright.
Okay.
So that...
I don't...
Ashes of what?
Okay.
Wait, I don't have enough?
What do I need?
Oh!
I need two more.
I have no stones.
It's okay.
I know...
I know a guy.
Where was he?
Is it him?
What the fuck was that guy?
Why should...
It's that guy!
That guy that was like...
The guy...
The guy that started kicking him.
Oh.
The girl you brought here.
She's crestfallen and can scarcely swing a blade.
But she has a gift.
For spirit tuning.
Oh, at the lake!
Yeah, I know him!
I know that guy!
The church!
There are many guys!
That's right!
I know many guys!
I'm...
I'm a guy for everything!
Okay.
Is that guy?
No, that's not him.
Guys, there's so many guys.
Oh, it's him!
There you go, there you go.
See, I told you!
I know a guy!
There he is.
There's like three guys.
Not every...
Okay, which stone was it?
Was it a one or...
Oh my god, I didn't pick...
Oh, it was one!
It was one because I had only...
I only had...
Uh...
Two.
I only had four.
Okay, there you go.
God, it's so far.
Alright.
Told you I knew a guy!
Told you chat!
Oh, Y and X instantly...
Oh!
Okay, that's gonna be...
That's nice to know.
Okay.
Here we go.
And then I need...
Four...
Okay, I need smithing stone too.
Don't worry!
I know a guy!
Oh wait, I can zoom out!
I still know so many!
Okay.
Alright, let me...
Okay, I was definitely incredibly underleveled.
I realized...
I realized when I was upgrading my weapon...
That may or may not have been incredibly...
Oh wait!
May or may not have been incredibly underleveled.
No, I need more stones!
I had...
I ran out of stones!
I ran out of these stones!
Oh wait!
No, I have enough!
Wait, no!
JK!
I don't need you!
I thought...
I thought it needed...
I needed 14...
I thought I had four, but...
I...
It was the opposite.
I'll need you no more.
Alright.
The guy I knew was actually you!
Sorry about that!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Okay, wait.
Okay, I need smithing stone 3.
Okay, I don't...
I don't know a guy for that.
Okay, now...
Which girl?
Isn't there a woman?
Which one?
Oh, her?
Where?!
Grr?
My name is Rodaarica.
I should've told you sooner.
Isn't this place impressive though?
The round table hold...
... Covert quarters of the two fingers, ...and gathering place of champions...
...who vied to become Elder Lord.
I never knew the guidance bestowed upon us tarnished.
Had such fantastic roots.
Although...
It's all a bit much for me, in truth.
Oh, she can treat my jellyfish?
Okay.
You're telling me I possess some kind of gift.
Oh my god, my jellyfish was also underleveled.
But if I do have this talent, and goodness knows it would be my first, I suppose I should try to hone it, shouldn't I?
I'll ask Master Hugh to teach me.
Certainly he does appear intimidating and holds no love for us tarnished.
Yeah, my jellyfish was literally at level zero.
I don't know how I got this far.
Oh, I know how.
With the power of a thousand drag wounds.
I suppose I should try to hone it, shouldn't I?
I'll ask Master Hugh to teach me.
Wait, what?
Who's Master Hugh?
Okay, you're not that.
You want to have a bear bear that lets you buy smithy stone from Roundtable?
No need to find your guy anymore?
Propsky, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's a blacksmith.
Okay.
Oh, it's a back and forth.
Hey, you might have a wonderful personality.
It's about the end of beauty!
I refuse to believe it.
I don't doubt you, but I know when something's too good to be true.
Alright.
Let's go.
Maybe she's blind.
If I do have a talent for spirit tuning.
And goodness knows that would be a surprise.
I suppose I should try to hone it, shouldn't I?
I'll ask Master Hugh to teach me.
Wait, what?
Wait, I already talked to him.
Oh!
I have to rest.
Pretend I didn't talk to you.
It's fine.
I'll just come back here.
Hello.
It's like I...
Oh, she's gone.
Wait, where did she go?
Oh, I actually have to wait an entire day?
Where the fuck did she go?
Oh, there she is.
Oh, she took off her hoods.
I couldn't tell.
Yeah, I like left the door and came back.
I walked out the door.
Oh, that fast?
I was out for like 10 seconds.
What I might be able to accomplish.
But if I might be able to help you all, I'd certainly like to try.
And if there's any chance to ease the suffering of my dear men...
My first found her?
Who is...
I don't...
Who is she?
Guys, I met so many maidens.
I don't even remember when I met her.
Pleased to make your acquaintance.
Okay.
Spear tuning.
I need the grave glove wart.
The fuck is that?
Guys, do I know a guy?
Wait, when did she...
She gave me that?
I didn't fucking adopt it?
Yeah, but what's the grave glove wart?
It's a flower.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Where the fuck is that flower?
Do I know a guy?
I explored those dungeons.
Where the fuck is that?
Catacombs?
I was in the catacombs?
There's a graveyard.
Oh, I didn't do a dungeon.
I...
Okay.
Here, there's a church here.
Maybe we'll find a dungeon here.
I skipped all of them.
That's fine.
Oh yeah, there's Santa.
Alright.
Let's find this dungeon.
Apparently, there's one here somewhere.
Is that a dungeon?
That's a building.
There's one north of the church.
Okay, north.
That's this way.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You skipped every...
How the fuck?
It's like...
It's like when I played Minecraft.
And we...
We...
Somehow...
Went past every fucking...
There was a castle there.
Look for the reaper.
Oh, there's a cat.
Oh, there it is.
Over here, I see it.
Yeah, every nether fortress.
Okay.
I'm too lazy.
It's right here.
That's a dungeon, right?
What?
Oh!
I'll live.
Okay.
It's this way.
You point it that way.
See, I told you I know a guy.
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
Alright, we gotta get the glove.
Alright, here I go.
Oh.
Maybe it's a baby dungeon because I haven't been in one yet.
Okay.
It might be a baby dungeon.
Proper death means returning to Earth Tree.
Have patience until the time comes.
And the root costs you.
Alright.
There's no way I could fuck this up.
It's a baby dungeon.
Oh!
Okay.
That was bullshit.
That was actually bullshit.
That...
That was...
Okay.
That was not fair.
That... that was not fair.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Be wary of left.
Oh, man.
I wish... I wish I... I read that.
Of course, the one message I decided to not read.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
There's a guy over there.
Does he throw something?
Do these things?
Okay.
There's multiple guys here.
Wait.
Is there more flowers?
Or, like, is that one flower I'm gonna find?
Come on.
I'll take you one by one.
Ow.
Okay.
Never mind.
Oh, there's more?
Okay.
Oh, what's this?
Summoning pool.
Oh, there's more?
Okay.
That's good.
Oh, it's like a little pig statue.
Look at this guy.
Oh, there's more.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
No, that's not what I wanted.
Oh, there is more.
Look at that.
Alright.
I'm just gonna heal up.
I don't trust myself.
Be wary of right.
What the fuck is that?
No fucking shit.
I should be wary.
Are I throwing?
Throwing what?
What do I throw?
Wait.
I can craft.
I'm missing one.
I...
Okay, maybe, guys.
Oh, I have that.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Thank god.
Oh, my god.
How do I do this?
Okay, here.
Oh, my god.
Where is the...
Where the fuck is the...
Where the fuck... Okay.
Guys, I'm trying to figure out...
I don't have...
I don't have arrows.
I think I don't have arrows.
Lower row?
Wait.
How do I get to my...
Oh.
The fuck?
How do I use my daggers?
How do I...
That's it.
Did it hit?
Guys, I don't think it hit.
I...
I don't think...
I don't think I hit it, guys.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
I'm just gonna run.
There's no point.
There actually...
I don't know why I even tried.
I...
I don't know why.
Fuck, I hit it?
Okay.
There we go.
I fucking knew you were a fake.
I knew.
Oh my god, but I didn't know you have friends!
I
got it!
He hit it!
Oh!
Thank you guys.
I...
Get out of here.
It worked out.
Okay, I got more ghost flowers.
I didn't know they could bring it back up.
Alright, I'll back up.
Two steps ahead.
I'm always two steps ahead.
It's you.
How?
Oh my god.
That's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm lit.
First off, down.
Watch your head and be worried.
Okay, we'll go down first.
Just to see why he said first off.
I love her.
Was my weapon not too... Oh my god, I didn't even notice.
What did I do with that?
Oh my god, you fucker!
I can't fucking...
Wait, why can't I move?
Oh my god, he fucking hit me when I couldn't move!
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I had to press Y.
Oh my god.
Alright.
It's time.
It's fine.
We got enough.
Oh, it's a cat.
Don't worry, I've got it.
Oh, I've seen this guy in Night Ring.
Holy fuck.
That's a big-ass cat.
That's not a rat.
Don't be lying to me.
He said it was a rat.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Alright.
Got greedy.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Too busy looking at him.
Oh, I got greedy again.
I never learned.
Why don't I ever learn?
Don't be afraid.
There we go.
We're fine.
Stop.
That's fine.
I learned now.
There we go.
On that degree.
Dog.
Oh, dog.
Turn to the entrance.
That's fine.
I learned.
Learning is burners.
We were definitely over-leveled.
Alright.
I learned.
No.
We are committed to the jellyfish.
Okay, maybe this time.
Okay, so there was a flower.
Is he still- Oh my god, he's still at it.
Yeah, I can make it.
I can make it.
I knew I could make it.
Wait, what?
Is there a guy following me?
Oh, hey.
I am.
Oh, there is the flower.
Oh, but what's over here?
Oh, I see you.
I fucking see you.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
I see you.
Get your ass over here.
Come on.
Get your ass over here, bitch.
Bitch.
Okay, I- I don't know, man.
Oh, fuck this.
I don't need that flower.
Fuck that.
I'll get this flower.
I'm leaving.
We could have that.
Alright, we go back.
We have our flower for our jellyfish.
Joki out.
Look at all these people that died to that cat thing.
It can't be me.
Not like I'm over leveled or anything.
I don't need that imps validation!
Alright, now I can level up the jellyfish.
Alright.
Time to finally evolve my jellyfish.
I want one day eventually accidentally hit him.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is that?
I didn't do an- I'm not doing another dungeon.
Let's go.
We're going in.
I'm not doing another dungeon, guys.
Here?
Where was it?
I don't remember.
Oh, thank god.
I keep worrying that I might accidentally...
Like...
Accidentally, like, hit her.
Where was it?
I don't remember.
Oh, debate parlor.
Okay, I have to go up the rocks.
Okay.
Alright, it's rock time.
Rock time!
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Jump down!
Nice.
I just know I have to go this way.
And I should make it.
Here we go.
I believe.
I believe... I believe in us, guys.
I...
I thought... I didn't realize the elevator wasn't there anymore.
I just... I just... I thought it was...
The elevator is quite black right now.
Okay.
Let's go back.
It's like, you know when it doesn't move, I can't see it.
When it doesn't move, it can't see it, you know?
Don't keep believing too hard.
Usually...
Oh my god.
Usually the elevator is on...
Usually the elevator is below on default.
How was I supposed to know it wasn't on default?
Get your goat.
My vision is based on movement.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, where am I?
Oh my god.
Oh, it's the teachers.
Oh, it's the Grand Professor.
Oh my god, that's so creepy.
It's the ultimate nerd.
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
There's so many of these nerds!
Where's the Grand Nerd?
There she is.
What?
What's that?
Oh, is that the wound?
A sweeting, fresh, and pure...
The jellyfish is a strong spirit!
I'll show you.
I'll show you all.
Oh, fuck my legs.
My knees.
Oh my god, I'm trying so hard to let... Oh, there she is.
Wait, no, where is she?
Oh my god, there she is.
I found her for real this time.
I was like, wait a minute.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I didn't realize that was a move.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Where are they singing?
Oh my god!
Who's singing?
Oh, they're not singing anymore.
Okay.
Stop singing!
All right.
No, I know there's phase two, guys.
I saw... I saw the... I saw a lot of people fighting this boss.
I know there's a... You can't fuck with me.
I...
Ah,
my beloved.
Have no fear.
I will hold thee...
Patience.
Oh, there he is.
I killed her.
That's why I killed your mom.
What you gonna do now?
I know you're a lot harder, but what you gonna do now?
Oh, shit.
Wait, you grew up so tall.
What the fuck?
You were just four!
Send word, far and wide.
Of the last queen of Karia.
Oh, where did she take me?
Oh my god.
Where did she take me?
Oh, that's her mom?
Oh, shit.
That's right.
I beat up your daughter.
What you gonna do now?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Where's my octopus?
Oh, there she is.
Oh my god.
Wait, she fucking just walked away?!
Okay.
Oh my god, that's fucking...
That's illegal.
Fuck her.
What's she doing?
Like, I don't know half of these moves that she's doing.
But to be fair, I am fighting her for the first time.
Oh my god, what's she doing?
What's she doing?
She's the fucking moon!
What do I do when she's the moon?!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I'll get...
Oh my god!
Oh no, no.
Okay.
Oh, you guys are praised!
I didn't see you guys are praised!
I
didn't see you guys are praised!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, not the moon.
Not the moon.
Oh!
Oh my god, now there's dogs!
Jesus fucking Christ.
Oh, what the fuck is that?!
I don't know where she is!
I'm so lost!
Oh my god!
No!
Oh, I got greedy!
I got so greedy!
I didn't...
I thought I could get the heal off!
I thought I could get it off!
I almost...
I got greedy!
Why do I always get so greedy?!
I just...
It was so low!
I saw it!
And I was like, I got this!
I could just...
Oh!
I...
I saw it!
And I was like...
Oh!
That's right!
I got you!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Leverage this!
Oh my god.
Okay, I didn't go through.
Oh...
No, now it's downhill!
Downhill.
I always do the best on my first try.
Now it's downhill, chat.
Oh my god.
Revenge of the Nerd.
I'll never learn to not be greedy.
I'll never learn.
That's the worst part.
Oh my god, and I did so well.
That's the worst part, too.
I actually was doing so well.
I'm so sad.
Huh.
The worst part is that I know that I'm not going to do as good as that run now.
Like, that was actually my best run.
That's going to be my best run.
And we all know it.
There we go.
Oh my god, a fucking course.
Where is he?
He's over there.
Okay.
Okay, here's one of them.
Where's the other singer?
Oh my god, where is he?
I don't see him.
Oh my god!
I don't know where the other fucking singer is!
I hear her!
Get out of me, you whore!
Oh, I see you!
That's the last one!
I know that's the last- Wait, that's not the last one?
Oh, I know that's the last one!
I know that's the last one!
One more hit!
Yes!
Okay!
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Go, squid.
Go.
Oh, fuck.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
Okay.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Why do you keep doing this to me?
Oh, my God.
Not the moon.
Not the moon!
Okay.
Jesus, he keeps... she keeps just...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I...
It's the range.
Okay.
All right.
Just gotta slowly walk over.
I just gotta slowly...
You fucker!
You actual fucker!
Oh, my God!
You had to send in the troll!
Yes.
Okay.
I hate you so much.
I don't trust myself.
I knew it!
Oh, my God.
Get closer, you fucking whore.
Get closer, you fucking whore!
Please!
It's fucking wolves.
Okay.
There you go.
She only lets me hit her once this time!
Oh, my God.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh
my god.
I hate you.
Oh my god.
Watch you.
I'm looking for you.
You fucker.
Oh my god.
No, you fucker!
Okay.
One hit.
That's fucking right!
Oh my god.
The wolves are coming.
Rush here.
Rush me.
Oh, he did it.
He did it.
I had to be so patient there.
Oh my god.
Oh, we did it.
You flee, my sweetings.
Come out from whence ye hide.
What's that?
There are books and light aplenty.
That's such a huge rune.
Come out, say I.
Or will ye be gravestones to be better born anew?
What are you talking to?
Me?
To become a sweeting...
Reborn of my beloved egg.
Oh, she's friend now?
Oh!
Wait, what's this for?
Reborn of my beloved egg.
And change how I look.
Wait, what's rebirth?
A larval tear is...
She respect... Oh, you can respect stats?
Oh!
Oh, so like if I don't like my stuff, I can reset everything.
Oh, I see.
I see.
What if I kill her?
Do I get...
If I kill her, do I get souls?
I don't need to respect anything.
All right, Vigor or Dex, guys?
He can...
Oh, she's...
God damn it.
I want her out of here.
I want that egg.
I want that giant ass rune.
Okay, Vigor to 30.
Oh, I can get it to 30.
All right, Vigor to 30.
We do it?
Vigor to 30, guys?
Okay, hit 30.
Okay, now what?
Dex?
The Arcane and Dex?
What's Arcane for?
We do...
Do we actually need Arcane?
Okay, I'll put one in Dex and one in Arcane.
Okay, I'll put one in the other.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
We did two bosses.
I'm going back to the round table.
Fuck this.
I'm going back home.
All right.
Oh, we're gonna call it here.
We did two bosses.
I need to pick up that today.
Oh, I can have new items.
Nice.
But thank you, everybody, for coming.
I really appreciate it, guys.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I'm gonna have to pick up that now.
But don't worry.
Tomorrow is a double stream day.
So you're just gonna be double the Doki's.
The double D's.
But thank you all for coming.
As I'm gonna go head out because I was supposed to pick him up like 30 an hour ago.
So I hope I don't get charged extra for taking a while to pick him up.
I really wanted to beat another boss.
Anyway, but don't worry.
It's a 24 hour hospital.
So like, he was getting a checkup done.
So, yeah.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pacha check.
Get him around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.